Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim. Sag mal, sind wir eigentlich ein linker Podcast.
Äh hoffentlich nicht, weil dann müssten wir uns ja jetzt distanzieren.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zwo zwo fünf am was haben wir heute? Den zehnten Juli,
zwanzig siebzehn. Wir sagen jetzt einfach mal das Datum. Ich weiß nicht, werde schon seit zehn Jahren gefragt, dass ich das doch äh all meinen Podcast mal tun soll. Ich vergesse es immer,
Aber hier, hier, hier ist es ganz äh ähm sinnvoll und äh gerade heute finde ich's äh nochmal besonders wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, dass wir jetzt hier an einem Montag zusammensitzen, nachdem in Hamburg ähm ja,
Schönes Wetter war und äh.
Hafengeburtstag. Annik, ähm.
Tja, was war denn? Ja, genau, in Hamburg hat's gegipfelt und äh da wir beide nicht vor Ort waren.
Haben wir uns noch Verstärkung eingeladen. Nämlich Johnniv Nebel, hallo.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Johnnys Nebel, Journalist, Blogger, Aktivist bekannt, äh spätestens aus Logbuchnetzpolitik hundertachtundsechzig, wo du schon mal bei uns zu Gast warst und äh.
Mit dem schönen Titel ist war nicht alles schlecht im Rechtsst.
Passt, das passt ja mal wieder.
Und ähm du äh bloggst unter Metronaut DE und hast auch einen unregelmäßigen Podcast zusammen mit äh wie heißt denn Kalle.
Keine Coinblum ähm unter mit unter dem Namen Metrolaut.
Und mit dir sprechen wir gleich über äh die Löcher, die in Hamburg aus dem Käse geflogen sind. Vorher müssen wir aber heute mal ein bisschen kurz noch äh um unserer Kunistenpflicht nachzukommen, erzählen, was denn so in der Netzpolitik,
passiert ist. Ich habe eine gute und eine schlechte Nachricht. Welche zuerst?
Die Gute, dann haben wir alle we.
Dann haben wir es hinter uns. Also die gute Nachricht ist
Die die VDS wurde außer Kraft gesetzt, es hatte sich ja angekündigt, äh nach der Entscheidung des Oberverwaltungsgerichtes Nordrhein-Westfalen vom zweiundzwanzigsten Juni zweitausendsiebzehn hat nämlich nun die ähm die Bundesnetzagentur
entschieden die Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorerst auszusetzen. Wir begrüßen das und sind gespannt
wie die Politik das jetzt nochmal in den Griff bekommen möchte. Die Hintergründe haben wir in der letzten Sendung schon besprochen, da geht es primär.
Um die Europarechtswidrigkeit der neuen deutschen Ausgestaltung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung etwas, was wir immer wieder
erwähnt und kritisiert haben, hat jetzt dann doch irgendwo auch einmal Gehör gefunden. Sicherlich ist das aber nicht das,
Ende dieser Geschichte, sondern ein Etappensieg.
Genau, aber äh ziemlich nachhaltig, also alle großen Provider haben jetzt sozusagen ihre Aktivitäten offiziell eingestellt, warten da äh wie sie selber dann sagen, die Hauptverhandlung ab,
und äh niemand hat da noch äh einen nennenswerte Hoffnung, dass diese Hauptverhandlung in irgendeiner Form anders ausfällt als dieses zwischenzeitliche Ergebnis,
was ich ja eigentlich nur auf einen Provider bezog, aber im Prinzip in seiner Auslegung her so generell ist und so unumstößlich daherkommt, dass äh ja man davon ausgehen kann, dass es erstmal keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung geben wird
Hucha.
Dann äh die schlechte Nachricht aus der Netzpolitik. Nein, es gibt natürlich wie immer mehrere schlechte Nachrichten. Ich habe euch ausge,
Ähm der Staatstrojaner ist jetzt auch durch den Bundesrat gegangen. Also hier geht es um die SDP Unovelle mit dem neu eingeführten Staatstrojaner auch bei,
gängiger Strafverfolgung, also alltäglicher Strafverfolgung, wie das sehr schön bei heiße bezeichnet wird, mit dem sehr breiten Straftatenkatalog, der nun.
Es ermöglicht den Staatsregner einzusetzen. Interessant finde ich immerhin, dass der mitberatende Verbraucherausschuss,
Empfohlen hatte den Vermittlungsausschuss anzurufen und die Initiative so zumindest zu verzögern. Ja, also immer wenn der äh Bundesrat sagt, nee, so finden wir es aber jetzt irgendwie nicht ganz so geil, so, dann muss der Vermittlungsausschuss eben gucken, dass man,
da irgendwie Frieden reinkriegt und die Argumentation, die der Verbraucherausschuss angebracht hat, äh
war oder zeigte sich besorgt, dass die gesetzlich vorgesehenen weitgehenden Befugnisse zu einer massiven Schwächung der IT-Sicherheitsstrukturen beitragen und Nutzer gefährden könnten.
Ähm das ist wie viele vielleicht sich erinnern, meine primäre Argumentation gewesen als Sachverständiger im Rechtsausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages, aber der
Verbraucherausschuss war natürlich nur mit beratend und nicht federführend. Ähm sodass diese Sache am Ende dann doch ähm aus dem,
also vom Bundesrat auch abgesegnet wurde und dieses Gesetz nun auf dem Weg ist eines zu werden.
Keine Überraschung hier.
Überraschung hier.
Dann gibt es ein seltener ähm ja aber ein seltenes aber immer wieder auftauchendes Thema bei Lokbuchnetzpolitik ist die Türkei.
Ähm dort sind am fünften Juli zweitausendsiebzehn acht ähm,
Na ja, das englische Wort ist Human Right Defender, also Menschenrechtsaktivisten äh Menschen.
Menschenrechtler, Menschenrechtler äh und zwei ähm Trainer oder Consultants äh festgenommen wurden. Äh auf der Insel Bouiucada, die ist an der äh an der Küste bei Istanbul,
wurden festgenommen, Nalan RCM, Samus, aus Bekli, Oslem Dalkiran,
wahrscheinlich ausgesprochen, Gunal Kursun, Ignor Ustun und Neat
Tastern und die beiden äh Trainer, die dort waren sind Ali Garaway,
Ali Garawi und Peter Stoldner. Und an dem letzten Namen erkennt man, dass es ein deutscher Name
und Peter Steudner ist neunzehnhunderteinundsiebzig geboren, hat in Berlin Politikwissenschaften studiert und hat eigentlich sein gesamtes Leben seither dem äh der der gewaltfreien
dem gewaltfreien Protest und vor allem der Nachsorge und Vorsorge
für politische Konflikte verschrieben, der hat in Mos Mosambik zwei Jahre gearbeitet an der psychosozialen Reintegration von Soldaten
bei der NGO ist das glaube ich in Cota äh gearbeitet, also eine.
Ähm Gruppe, die sich im äh entwicklungspolitischen Bereich engagiert zusammen mit Kirchengemeinden, so Weltläden, also alles.
In Kota, in Kota Netzwerk heißt es, glaube ich.
Das Incotra Netzwerk, genau. Ähm so eine alles immer so eine äh gewaltfrei ähm
Der Kampf für Menschenrechte. Ähm und außerdem insbesondere sich dann auch noch so der der äh
Gesundheitsvorsorge, also so gewaltfreie Kommunikation, Konfliktanalyse, Selbstreflexion, Konflikttransformation, also so so Hardcore äh gewaltfrei ähm.
Engagiert im Wendland und so weiter. Das macht er äh seit Ewigkeiten ähm seit zweitausendfünfzehn macht er außerdem Informationssicherheitstrainings. Also auch hier äh Vorbeugung und und äh defensive
ähm defensives Engagement.
Für Menschenrechtler oder Menschenrechtsaktivisten und ja in dieser Kapazität wurde er jetzt gerade in ähm in Istanbul verhaftet, ist seit dem fünften Juli ähm dort in ähm.
In Gefangenschaft. Er hat äh zusammen mit Ali,
Garawi, ein äh iranisch-schwedischer Autor äh Theater äh Schreiber, also Drehbuchautor,
und auch Informationssicherheitsberater ähm äh ist er da jetzt also in
einer Polizeidirektion in Istanbul gefangen. Ich kriege da auch immer Updates, wo die sich gerade befinden. Wir hatten äh minimale Gesundheit, gesundheitliche Probleme konnten äh einen Arzt sehen, haben auch,
äh rechtlichen Beistand, aber ihnen wird ähm wurde bisher äh es nicht ermöglicht, mit den mit dem Konsulat zu sprechen. Also das ist eine, mein Fünf-Tage-In, in Istanbul,
in Gefangenschaft ist noch nicht lange. Die lassen einen da gerne mal am längeren Abend verhungern, aber wir werden diesen Fall sehr,
genau und sehr kritisch begleiten und hoffen, dass der Peter und natürlich auch alle anderen,
möglichst bald,
wieder freikommen. Gleichzeitig sollte, wenn man über die Türkei redet, erwähnt werden, dass dort gerade der türkische Oppositionspolitiker Keymal Kilic Daroglu
Vierhundertfünfundzwanzig Kilometer marschiert es, um ein Zeichen gegen Staatschef Erdogan zu setzen.
Hat dort eine Abschlusskundgebung in Istanbul abgehalten und äh da waren irgendwie weiß ich nicht wieder also Menschen, Massen unvorstellbar äh.
Also je nachdem wem man glauben darf, bis zu eins Komma sechs Millionen Leute, die dann in Istanbul zusammengekommen sind am Schluss.
Also der größte Protest sei es äh.
Seit Gesipark und auch also auf jeden Fall.
Eigentlich größer sogar noch haben.
Hör mal, wart, wart ihr nicht da auch mit eurem Podcast im Gazi-P.
Wir waren auch beim GESI Park, ja. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein großer äh.
Es ist ein riesen, also nach jetzt nach dem Referendum der größte Protest, ne? Da waren dann bisher nur ein paar tausend Leute auf den Straßen und das ist jetzt ernst zu nehmen, traut sich nicht mal Erdogan.
Tun.
Gegangen sind, ne? Also CRP ist ja diese Kimalistenpartei, die eigentlich ja früher mal das Heft in der Hand gehabt hat in der Türkei, die aber irgendwie unfähig war, sich diesen ganzen Erdogan-Trend
ausreichend entgegenzustellen und jetzt macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob sie etwas spät nachdem dann irgendwie, glaube ich, sein, sein Co-Chef äh
genommen wurde, da äh haben sie dann sozusagen bei ihren Freiheitsgedanken ausreichend entdeckt und dann hat er aber was für seine Verhältnisse relativ beeindruckendes getan, die man halt einfach nur
Mit einem Wort in der Hand quasi äh was war das äh
ich habe ja kein türkisch, also keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall Gerechtigkeit, das ist sozusagen auch auf dieser Abschlussveranstaltung das einzig erlaubte Plakat gewesen, um da sozusagen
ne? Also sich gar nicht erst irgendwas vorwerfen zu lassen, dass man jetzt hier irgendwas anzetteln würde. Bemerkenswert, dass man so viel
ähm ja so vorsichtig da vorgehen muss, aber ich denke, das ist halt alles keine große Überraschung. Zumindest ist das jetzt alles nicht niedergeknüppelt worden. Das äh wäre vielleicht nach hinten losgegangen
Und vor allem ist es halt mal ein Protest, der eben jetzt nicht so, ich sage mal, links geprägt ist, ja
sondern der eben die ganze Breite der Gesellschaft auch mitgenommen hat, weil halt einfach jetzt alle Leute sich dem angeschlossen haben, die in irgendeiner Form von den Aktionen der Regierung der letzten Jahren betroffen waren
trifft ja Akademiker und alle Leute, die entlassen wurden, Journalisten et cetera. Ob das, was äh auslösen wird, werden wir sehen.
Findet auf jeden Fall statt und soweit ganz gut, trotzdem ist Erdogan ja ganz fleißig dabei, auch noch weitere Leute festzunehmen. Auch die Chefin der äh Amnesty International
das International Ablegers in der Türkei ist jetzt auch festgenommen worden, nun kein Ende, man wundert sich, dass überhaupt noch jemand da ist, den man noch festnehmen kann.
Ja gleichzeitig umso krasser ist so viele Leute auf die Straße gehen und da bisher noch nicht mit einem Wasserwerfer reingeballert wurde äh wie es ja in der Türkei gerne auch mal passiert.
Ja, das machen die halt in diesen Staaten, ne? Also mit diesen, dass sie da.
In diesen Demokraturen, da also wenn da auf einmal ein paar Leut.
Wasserwerfer einsetz.
Protestieren und so.
Wer schützt das schon? Ja gut, dass bei uns sowas nicht.
Gut, dass wir in Deutschland leben, da kennen wir das alles nicht, ne?
Ähm.
Vielleicht für die für die Leute, die noch nicht so Demonstrationsveteran sind wie du. Dann fangen wir doch mal das Thema G zwanzig in Hamburg mit einer kleinen Gipfelkunde an. Ähm,
Diese Gipfel immer mit wechselnder Zahl, ne? Es gibt irgendwie G mal G sieben, mal G acht mal G zwanzig.
Unterschiedliche Vereine, ne? Also ähm ja, vielleicht k.
Sag mal, also es gibt diese, was, so ein Gipfel geht drei Tage.
Zwei, drei Tage, je nachdem, wann. Und man hat dann am Ende gibt's eine eine Abschlusskundgebung, die ist aber in der äh eine Abschlusserklärung. Die ist aber in der Regel vorher von den Unterhändlern ausgehandelt worden.
Genau, da gibt's Sharepars, äh, sogenannte, die im Vorfeld äh für solche Gipfel wir sind einfach vorbereiten und dann ich glaub.
Da wird er halt dazu gelächelt dann noch ein bisschen.
Sharepard, ne, wie auch wenn man auf so einen Moin Everes steigt, dann hat man auch einen Sharepark, das ist der, der einen am Ende noch die letzten Meter hochzieht.
Das sind auch die, die die ganze Arbeit, die ganze Arbeit machen.
Der, der das ganze Gepäck da hochträgt, weißt du wie schwer das ist. Äh so ist er
So, ne? Und ähm also die, die am Ende wenig äh wenig äh Lob für ihre ganze Arbeit kriegen. Äh wie das eben so ist mit so, da hast du also eine Scherper, der der handelt das dann aus, dann gibt's eine Abschlusskund
äh Abschlusserklärung und äh eine ganze Reihe Fototermine, Samstag, Freitagabend, vielleicht noch ein Konzert oder so und ähm.
Um sowas eben zu veranstalten, weil man da so viele Leute auf einem Haufen hat, äh erfordert das natürlich auch
entsprechende Sicherheitsvorkehrungen und das geht gerne auch mal schief. Wir erinnern uns da an Genua, was in Genua.
Ja, ich war auf einigen Gipfeln war in Genua, das war so, also meine Protesterfahrung, glaube ich, das wahrscheinlich
härteste oder auch prägendste Ereignis. Genua war die Situation, die Globalisierungsbewegung gerade riesig groß nach dem nach Seattle, ne? Da da ging das los und äh
In Genua waren hunderttausende von Leute und es gab ging auch über mehrere Tage und es gab verschiedene Aktionsformen. Eigentlich so ähnlich wie jetzt auch in Hamburg ähm,
und äh das wurde in einer Brutalität äh.
Niedergeschlagen, so dass dann auch später jemand ein Demonstrant Carlo Juliani
erschossen wurde aus einem Jeep heraus. Es gab Folterszenen in in Poliz, in in Gefangenensammelstelle. Der wollte eine Schule üble Misshandlungen, Folter und so. Also es war äh
harte Bilder und das hat eigentlich so dazu geführt, dass diese Gipfel eigentlich äh,
Zumindest in sagen wir in Demokratien nicht mehr in großen Städten stattfinden, ne? Also einfach weil äh,
Weil das dazu führt, dass dass es dass es schwer kontrollierbar ist und dass es zu dazu führt, dass das eben äh diese unschönen Bilder gibt bei der sich Demokratien dann soweit aus dem Fenster lehnen, dass es schwierig wir.
Das ist, dass sie wie Schüsse fallen, dass Menschen ernst. Es gibt glaube ich auch, also diese Eskalation in Genua kann man jetzt lange drüber reden, wurde ja auch noch, weiß ich nicht, Jahre oder Jahrzehnte von äh von den Gerichten offenen, jetzt gerade Urteile gefallen, ne.
Jetzt gerade Urteile wie Urteile wieder gefallen, es wurden da auch Leute bestraft für ähm natürlich sehr spät und also okay aber ich glaube, wenn wir diese Geschichte vergehen war.
Um mal nur kurz die Situation zu, wenn du sowas in einer Stadt machst, dann hast du erstens eine ganze Menge Menschen, die da wohnen, die wollen in Ruhe klarkommen
Und natürlich, wenn du jetzt irgendwie in Genua warst ja, glaube ich, G acht, äh, wenn du jetzt in Hamburg dein G zwanzig, die zwanzig äh wichtigsten Staatenlenker
und ihre kompletten äh Entouragen, die irgendwie zwischen fünfzig und zweihundert Personen nochmal sind, versammelst, dann musst du natürlich,
Grundsätzlich, erstmal für deren Sicherheit sorgen
Ja, also nicht nur unbedingt, weil es Demonstrationen gibt, sondern natürlich auch, weil es ein attraktives Ziel ist, um da jetzt einfach eine Bombe drauf zu werfen oder mal irgendwie einen abzuknallen oder so, ne? Wenn Terror ist da auch ein Thema, eines, was jetzt,
Gott Lob in äh beim G zwanzig wieder keinen äh keine Rolle gespielt hat, wobei es natürlich einige Leute gibt, die da mit den Vokabeln durcheinander kommen. Ähm.
Aber du musst diese Leute schützen und es ist natürlich einfacher, dass äh irgendwo auf dem Land zu machen, ne, wie der darauffolgende Gipfel war dann glaube ich, Heiligendamm.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, heilige Gesamtspiel später. Also ich,
vielleicht nochmal, also ich ich glaube polizeilich ist, ist so ein Gipfel in der Großstadt mit ich habe Staatschefs mit höchsten Sicherheitsanforderungen, ich habe irgendwie Demonstranten
hunderttausende, ich habe ganz unterschiedliche demonstrierende in in der Stadt, ich habe da Leute, die wollen da friedlich demonstrieren, ich habe Leute, die wollen zivilen Ungehorsam machen mit Blockaden und ich habe Leute, die wollen irgendwie auch irgendwie, die wollen das brennen sehen und man hat so eine, so eine, eine
eine Melange quasi die
die die schwierig ist. Also es ist 'ne Herausforderung also polizeilich ist das schon so das Härteste was man machen kann.
Ich war dann zwei Jahre später in einem Gipfel, das war wie Evionk ein kleines Städtchen, ne? Äh die Proteste waren damals nicht in Nevian, sondern die waren in Genf und in Losan. Und da war schon Eviant, liegt irgendwie.
Irgendwie liegt auf der anderen Seite des Sees irgendwie des Genfer Sees. Man kann das irgendwie dicht machen. Ähm,
Das war so die das was danach kam, ne und Heiligendamm dann äh war ja auch, ne, das ist
Ostseebad. Ich habe da wenig Zufahrtsstraßen. Ich habe das auf dem Land, ich kann mache da einen Zaun außen rum und dann dann habe ich diese diese Situation
Ähm also hier auch wieder, ne? Also wenn man also.
Mhm. Man sieht da den.
Dann gab's noch den G acht Gipfel, den nächsten im deutschen Land nach Heiligendamm, war dann in Ellmau, das ist irgendwie in Bergen, ein kleines Nest, was hier auch abschotten kann. Und jetzt,
Kommt auf einmal wieder äh dass man äh einen Gipfel in einer in einer Stadt macht, ne. Also das ist,
diese Ansage, wir machen jetzt den G zwanzig, da bin ich auch nicht nur acht Staatschefs, sondern zwanzig, ähm was die Sache dann nicht unbedingt einfacher macht. Ähm und jetzt gehen wir nach Hamburg.
Und ich glaube, da.
Hamburg hat wie viele Einwohner.
Ich glaube, knapp zwei Millionen, oder?
Die hast du sowieso schon mal durchs Bild hinten, dann hast du die ganzen also Unmengen an Straßen, Straßen, Zügen. Das ist eigentlich eine Situation, die kriegst du also die kriegst du jetzt polizeitechnisch nicht im Griff, oder?
Also ich meine, das ist für ein Militär problematisch so eine Stadt unter Kontrolle zu halten. Ähm aber doch eigentlich für eine Polizei doch glaube ich kaum,
zu schaffen.
Also ich ich glaube, dass es einfach eine, also das hat haben wir als vorherige Gipfel in Städten wie Sea Hattle oder Genua gezeigt, dass das
höchste Schwierigkeiten gibt äh
damit klar zu kommen, einerseits ist, man kann das Ganze in Frage stellen von verschiedenen Seiten her, muss ich nach Stadt von zwei Millionen Leuten so eine Scheiße zumuten, dass sie über Wochen und Tage irgendwie lahmgelegt werden und von einem Viertel zum nächsten oder ich fahre einmal durch die Stadt und brauche vier Stunden, muss ich das eigentlich machen, damit's.
Warum treffen die sie nicht auf dem Flugzeugträger oder auf einer Insel oder was? Das ist eine eine Frage. Ich muss sich die Leute damit belasten, da kann man natürlich gegenargumentieren und sagen, ja, aber in einer Demokratie muss es doch möglich sein, dass die sich in der Stadt treffen
Kann man drüber sprechen.
Reden wir mal drüber, was was für ein Ausmaß haben wir denn hier? Also in Hamburg, ich arbeite ja öfter in Hamburg, waren schon vor Monaten irgendwelche Park
Plätze komplett voll mit irgendwelchen äh Polizei ähm Camps, die
Planung ging irgendwie seit wie vielen Jahren, haben die da sich darauf vorbereitet.
Weiß ich nicht genau, ob es schon auf jeden Fall ist der Polizei.
Das steht erst so seit zwei Jahren fest, dass das ist, ne?
Ja, da, also so ungefähr ging so lange oder relativ lange ging da schon die Vorbereitung. Ich weiß, dass ich das war, glaube ich, schon im letzten Jahr, als ich irgendwie erste,
größere Absperrungen und Bekanntgaben da in Hamburg verfolgt haben,
Freunde aus sagten so, ja ähm das ist irgendwie kacke hier so, das finden wir doof, dass das bei uns vor der Tür stattfindet und die ganze Stadt in ein gewollt oder ungewollt, egal was da jetzt passiert wäre, in einen Ausnahmezustand versetzt und zwar über
ewig über was weiß ich weit länger als eine Woche.
Genau, also das Ganze ist ein riesen Aufwand, du musst das auch polizeilich natürlich so sehen, das ist, da wird eine Aufbauorganisation dann gemacht und dann kommt es, das ist eine Aufgabe der gesamten deutschen Polizei, Geheimdienste et cetera, die die dort dann äh äh
auch zusammengetrommelt wird quasi, das
es ist ein Mammutding, eine Sicherheit von so einem Gipfel in der Stadt zu machen. Also das ist schon nicht ganz einfach.
Was noch eher Wasser auf dazu kommt. Ich meine,
In Hamburg hätte er ja auch irgendwo stattfinden können, sondern es musste natürlich auch noch mitten in der City sein, in den Messehallen direkt angrenzend an einfach stark links geprägte äh Viertel, Schanzenviertel, Sankt Pauli
ähm Gängeviertel et cetera, auch kurz, also ist sozusagen man hat sich man hat die rote Zone quasi mitten in den in den Widerstandsbereich in den potenziellen hineingesetzt und auch das ist natürlich schon mal ein Affront für sich.
Was? Äh genau, vielleicht diese beiden Begriffe rote Zone, blaue Zone.
Genau, also wenn man äh in in so einer äh
Gipfelsituationen in der Stadt, aber auch auf dem Land äh werden oft so Zonen eingerichtet, also die rote Zone ist quasi, da darf gar niemand mehr rein, beziehungsweise wenn du da wohnst, aber selbst dann musst du dir die Fenster zuhalten und also das ist so die Zone, wo
Gipfel wirklich stattfindet.
Hochsicherheitsbereich.
Hochsicherheitsbereich, genau, da ist also.
Kein Rumlungern.
Da ist darf niemand rein und dann äh neben dieser roten Zone gab's die blaue Zone, die mit einer allgemeinen Verfügung äh,
quasi geschützt wird und in dieser Allgemeinverfügung ist dann Demonstrationsverbot zum Beispiel drin. Also man darf dann in einer
der blauen Zone, die fast, die hat achtunddreißig Quadratkilometer in Hamburg ausgemacht, also ein riesen Gebiet, ne, dass dann auch so äh wurde als Transferkorridor, ne, also dass man.
Das ist der Transfer.
Um um um die um die Konvois, ne? Also das sind ja fünftausend Gipfelteilnehmer quasi, diese ganze Entourage, die da dranhängt und eben die Leute durch die Gegend karren von den Hotels und so. Was man als Transferkorridor gerechtfertigt und macht eben
quasi einen großen Teil der Stadt wird zur Demonstrationsfreien Zone erklärt.
Das geht von von Fulsbül bis Neustadt am am siebten Juli noch die Hafencity mit dazu und von Logstedt bis Barmbek, also einmal das ist ja bleibt nicht mehr viel Hamburg über.
Es ist im Prinzip komplett Hamburg Nord. Also äh als.
Nördlich der Elbe.
Und nördlich der Elbe genau. Mhm.
Also genau, es wird eine Zone gemacht und in dieser Zone darf eben keine dürfen keine Versammlung stattfinden.
Am siebten und am achten Juli, wenn der Gipfel ist, genau.
Und was dann äh,
die Idee natürlich, wenn ich Gipfelproteste mache, also ich kann habe ja jetzt verschiedene Optionen, ich kann eine Großdemo irgendwie machen, sage okay, wir machen das nicht in dieser roten Zone oder in der blauen Zone,
in der roten sowieso nicht. Äh nach der Großdemonstration
zeigt ihm symbolisch seinen Protest und dann gibt's andere Formen, die sagen halt, wir machen zivil Ungehorsam, wir möchten da auf die Protokollstrecke, also Protokollstrecke ist immer
irgendwie quasi, da kommt dann die japanische Delegation und dann wenn auf der Protokollstrecke Leute sind, dann fahren die halt nicht, ne? Und dann müssen die halt anhalten aus Sicherheitsgründen und die Idee.
Protokollstrecker äh die es auch in diesem Korridor dann, oder.
Die sind genau in diesem Korridor, also in der in dieser äh in dieser blauen Zone, da gehen quasi die Strecken durch, auf denen die rumfahren, die Staatschefs.
Daran lag das wahrscheinlich, aber da kommen wir vielleicht später nochmal zu. Also so jetzt gibt's eine,
Frage, wer, wer tut sich das denn an, ne? Also ich meine, die, du holst dir ja nicht hoffentlich keine unerfahrenen
Leute dazu und du wirst wahrscheinlich auch Polizisten abbestellen. Das macht ja nicht die Hamburger Polizei neben Streife laufen, sondern da holst du dir irgendwelche Sicherheitsexperten.
Genau, also da da wird einen schon ein Jahr vorher äh
der wird es aufgebaut, dann wird überlegt, welche Einheiten Human, dann wird von allen Bundesländern werden Polizeieinheiten angefordert, damit die Bundespolizei da reingeholt, da werden Spezialeinheiten äh reingeholt, da werden,
Spezialeinheiten aus dem Ausland reingeholt, da werden Polizisten aus dem Ausland zum Beispiel aus Österreich äh mit dazugeholt. Also das ist so ein bisschen neues Phänomen. Äh nicht ganz neu, aber doch, dass dass die auch wirklich dann eingesetzt werden und nicht so ein, nur so ein Beobachterstatus haben. Ähm,
Und äh das Ganze wird wurde dann äh an äh der Einsatzleiter dieser ganzen Operation quasi wurde Hartmut, Dude und Hartmut Dude ist ein Hamburg, ein,
berüchtigter Polizist, ein Polizeidirektor, das ist so das ist ein sehr hohes Amt in der Polizei hier,
Module ist bekannt wurde von Ronald Schill damals diese Rechtsaußen Schildpartei.
Richter gnadenlos.
Gnadenlos, ne? Hat sich Polizist gnadenlos dann dazu geholt. Ähm, als er damals Innensenator war und da ist berufen worden,
und Dude ist bekannt für die, für die Hamburger Linie, das ist eigentlich so die also die die harte Hand, also nicht die ausgestreckte Hand, sondern die harte Hand der Polizei bei bei Versammlungen, Protesten, Ausschreitungen et cetera.
Wodurch drückt die sich aus? Die Hamburger Linie? Äh.
Die Hamburger Linie Hamburg liebt Wasserwerfer bei der Polizei, das ist so also in Berlin sieht man ja sehr selten Wasserwerfereinsätze. Die stehen da nur rum, um Eindruck zu machen. In Hamburg wird das die ganze Zeit eingesetzt. Also Wasser ist so, der Hamburger, da ist Wasserwerfer
irgendwie.
Ist ja auch eine Hafenstadt, ne? Also.
Kurze Korrektur, also die Dipidia behauptet, er sei von äh Michael Neumann berufen worden. Zwanzig zwölf.
Habe ich nichts mit zu tun. Zum äh zum Chef der Direktion Einsatz. Na ja okay.
Also von Schill finde ich jetzt hier zumindest äh gerade äh nichts. Nur falls uns das gleich wieder.
Okay, falls ihr uns, falls ihr da okay.
Ne? Okay. Egal. Er ist da.
Hamburger, Hamburgerlinie heißt Demonstration.
Hartes Vorgehen.
Gibt so so Linien, also zum Beispiel es gibt die Berliner Linie, die ist bei Hausbesetzung heißt, wir gehen da sofort rein und machen da, machen das platt. So oder räumen die Leute, ne? Und Hamburgerlinie ist eben als das harte Vorgehen gegen Demonstranten,
wird verstanden und das ist halt eng mit der Person Dudel, also der ist die Hamburger Linie quasi.
Was gibt's denn, was gibt's denn für andere Strategien im Umgang mit mit Demonstration? Also wenn man jetzt sagt, Hamburger Linie,
äh meine man erinnert sich vielleicht an Demonstrationen, wann war das zwar wahrscheinlich zweitausenddreizehn irgendwie so Schanzenvierteldemo, diese die sind auch nur ein paar Meter weit gekommen,
äh wurde, wurden die Wasserwerfer entleert, dann kam die nächste Ladung Wasserwerfer und das Ganze äh artete also da hatte einfach keine Demonstration stattgefunden, ne? Also.
Ja, also es gibt verschiedene äh jetzt gehen wir sehr in diese Polizeitaktiken rein, aber äh es es gibt unterschiedliche Strategien und lange Zeit war die Strategie, die Polizeien hatten quasi, ich habe
Wasserwerfer und Kräfte und die kommen Rücken in einer Front vor
und treiben dann die Demonstranten an die nächste Ecke, dann teilen sich die Demonstranten, dann teilen sich die und ich räume durch quasi, wie du das in der Pressekonferenz gestern sagte, also ich habe schon Frontenkrieg
so ein bisschen, ne?
Also ich habe so eine Front, die schiebt sich vor. Das ist so der Oldschool-Teil in Berlin ist man zweitausendfünf, sechs äh am ersten Mai äh oder er ist zu einem anderen äh äh Taktik übergegangen, die deutlich modernere Crowd Control Taktik eigentlich ist. Das ist
Berliner Durchmischung oder durch Mischung Vermengungstaktik die bedeutet ich gehe mit Kräften direkt in die.
Menge Menschenmenge rein und habe durch diese Vermischung,
überhaupt kein Angriff, also einerseits zeige ich, okay, ich nehme dich gleich fest, ich, wir haben das hier unter Kontrolle, wir trauen uns hier rein, also ich zeige Stärke, indem ich mittendrin stehe ähm und andererseits äh biete ich keine Angriffsfläche, weil nur also weil weil wir,
das ist sehr, ist sehr gefährlich dann in einer Menge dann Steine zu werfen gegen Polizei, wo drei Meter hier nebendran schon wieder Demonstranten stehen, das ist das führt eigentlich dazu, dass keine oder sehr wenig Gegenstände geworfen werden
Gleichzeitig sind diese diese Truppen, diese so ein bisschen Schildkrötenformation oder in Ketten durchgehen, haben dann gibt's noch Festnahmeeinheiten, die dabei sind und die dann direkt auf Straftäter quasi,
losgehen, die Festleben rausziehen und und das ist.
Auch quasi, dass das Entstehen größerer Gruppen von vorne herein zu verhindern, ne? Also und diese Berliner Durchmischung ist doch eigentlich eine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Es ist das ist eigentlich ein sehr ätzendes Konzept für äh auch zu einer Demonstrationsfreiheitssicht, weil man wenn man sehr äh sich weil es.
Weil du nicht mehr eine Demonstration bist, sondern so eine polizeilich kontrollierte ähm Menge irgendwie, aber es ist aus polizeilicher Sicht glaube ich ein intelligentes Konzept, weil es, weil es eben,
deutlich die Zahl von äh Straftaten und Gewalt äh senkt und hat sich in Berlin eigentlich bewährt, wenn man den ersten Mai anschaut, ist das mittlerweile dieses dieses Frontenlinienkampf irgendwie ist halt oldschool. Aber Dudel ist halt,
Oldschool, der ist Linienkampfwasserwerfer äh äh und auch nicht so Festnahme übrigens war, okay, da können wir später nochmal zukommen, als.
Nicht so festnahmefreudig.
Nee, weniger.
Festnahme intensiv.
Festnahme intensiv. Also okay, das ist grundsätzlich so ein Ding, also Dude ist bekannt für für die die harte Hand, er ist der härteste Hund, der
Zig Einsätze von ihm wurden im Nachhinein von Gerichten als rechtswidrig erklärt, dass es eine Kampfansage, wenn ich sage, wir machen ja G zwanzig und Dude ist hier der gesamte Polizeileiter, dann.
Ist schon klar, was was für eine Strategie äh da gefahren wird.
Das war auch der, der, ist das ja, der in den Medien dann äh anfangs immer zitiert wurde mit wir haben das komplette Arsenal hier und äh wenn wir müssen, werden wir das auch einsetzen und äh beschrieben wird als danach sehr schmale Pichgrinsen. Ist das ja, als.
Ja, der hat so einen, der hat so einen ähm trockenen.
Eine humor weiß ich nicht, aber es ist ein sehr trockener Typ, der war auch gestern in der Pressekonferenz eigentlich der einzige, der da noch der da irgendwie souverän wirkte.
Sich keiner Schuld bewusst war.
Genau, also der weiß ich keine Schuld bewusst auf jeden Fall, ja. Also kam zumindest so rüber.
Na gut, also das war die, das war die die Aussicht, die die Wettervorhersage in Hamburg für den Gipfel der härteste Einsatzleiter mit einer sehr konfrontativen,
Strategie, der nicht zögern wird, äh das Ganze in in Wasser und äh und Einsatz äh aufgehen zu lassen äh ist bekannt
dass er das, dass er da die die führende Hand hat. Ähm.
Man sagt ihm auch nach, also dass er da auch so ein tiefes, persönliches Anliegen gegen Linke vorzugehen,
weiß ich nicht genau, wer ob da wie, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht jemand, der irgendwie sagt, okay, jetzt lassen wir uns mal reden, wie kriegen wir das Ding denn easy über die Bühne, sondern wir werden eher durch Stärke zeigen, dass wir das über die Bühne kriegen, ne? Also das ist eine andere Art von Polizeiarbeit.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass die Bevölkerung, also grundsätzlich hatte man den Eindruck, dass jetzt nicht viele Leute in Hamburg sagten, ey geil, äh die Welt zu Gast bei Freunden,
Ne, die sagten eher so, ey, das ist ein Scheiß. Warum liegt ihr hier unsere Stadt äh
äh Lahm. Jetzt haben wir da noch diese Polizei äh irgendwie müssen irgendwie unsere Einkaufstüten kontrollieren lassen und hm Hamburg hatte relativ wenig,
Sympathie für diese Entscheidung, den Gipfel dort abzuhalten und zu Beginn ja auch eigentlich eine sehr,
ähm sehr positive äh Grundstimmung äh für die zu den Demonstranten. Vielleicht kann man an der Stelle noch deinen Artikel äh,
erwähnen über den Schutz vor Pfefferspray. Du hattest irgendwie einen Artikel geschrieben, so schützt ihr euch gegen Pfefferspray.
Äh ja, hatte ich äh gemacht, genau, einfach aus so äh Erfahrungswerten, weil der Pfefferspray beschäftigt mich als Thema schon lange äh mittlerweile inklationär und auch sehr oft rechtswidrig benutzt wird. Ähm,
und.
Und ja, einfach da kann man sich schützen, gibt so Mittel wie Okulaven oder wie äh Maloxan, was man mit Wasser verrührt und dann kann man sich danach irgendwie das zumindest bisschen einfacher aus den Augen und von der Haut wischen. Ähm ja, also wenn wir nochmal auf diese.
Äh dein Artikel hat dazu geführt, dass in den Apotheken das Zeug ausverkauft war, wenn ich das richtig verstanden.
Naja, weil sie nicht genau, ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nicht ein Geheimnis, Alter, die aber es hat dazu geführt, also mein ein Freund von mir äh hat mich dann geschrieben, ich war grad in der Apotheke und die die wissen schon Maloxan ist jetzt, ist für Pfefferspray, Fragen nach, man, ja, die Nachfrage ist so groß und
für das Oculaven-Nitt, da mussten sie in Niedersachsen irgendwie die Lager aufmachen,
um irgendwie das Zeug ranzukarren, also ist auf jeden Fall hat sich glaube ich halb Hamburg, also wer da geblieben ist, hatte irgendwie sich gegen Pfefferspray geschützt, ich glaube das auch also ist auf einmal eine gute Sache.
Pfefferspray klingt, ähm klingt so lustig.
Reizgas.
Ist ein Reizgas, wenn du das, also wie war das schon mal, wenn du das in Deutschland als Zivilist kaufst, steht drauf, äh nicht auf Menschen sprühen, nur zur Abwehr gegen aggressive Tiere, wenn du das
im Krieg einsetzen würdest, wäre das ein Verstoß gegen die Genfer Konvention, weil das Zeug zu schmerzhaft ist?
Genau und wenn es gegen eine Sitzblockade einsetzt, dann ist das ein ganz verhältnismäßiger Einsa.
Als Polizist. Ähm.
Ähm das Gemeinde an Pfefferspray ist, es ist halt einfach der pure Schmerz, ne? Es ist Kapsalizin drin, das ist das, was ähm
den Hitzeschmerzsensoren äh an Zunge und Augen sagt
ähm hier ist jetzt Brennen, hier ist jetzt Feuer. Das ist also nicht äh nicht zu unterscheiden, so 'ne sensorische Wahrnehmung, dass die ähm
die im die das, was der Körper empfindet ist die Augen stehen in Flammen und das was ich spüre ist Hitze oder der Mund und
äh der die Atem auch. Wenn man das Zeug nicht gewöhnt ist, kriegt man da gerne mal äh Kreislaufschwierigkeiten, weil der Körper denkt, er verblutet vor lauter Feuer. Und ähm das ist, also ist wirklich nicht angenehm. Können wir, glaube ich, beide sagen, das Zeug ist nicht schön
Aber das wird äh literweise da äh.
Genau und es setzt halt also wenn ich das mal abbekommen habe, äh setzt es mich äh auf jeden Fall für eine halbe Stunde außer Kraft. Wenn man nicht so gut im Mittelsinn hat, vielleicht nur eine Viertelstunde so richtig außer Kraft, aber ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall hart und es wurde,
Kann man vielleicht schon mal vorwegnehmen, sehr stark eingesetzt und viel.
So, dann ähm kommen wir doch mal so da so viel zur Vorgeschichte.
Dann gab es im Vorfeld schon, jetzt reden wir von dem Sonntag eine Woche vorher, ne? Also dem, was war das dann? Der,
Der zweite, zweite Juli, ne? Ähm, da ging's dann langsam los, denn wie das so ist, man kann bei so einem Gipfel damit rechnen, dass sehr viele Leute auch von von außerhalb anreisen.
Also ich würde, ich würde sogar noch fast nochmal zurück ein Stück zurückgehen. Ja, also mich dazu immer die, also
gibt dann bei so einem Gipfel natürlich große äh zivilgesellschaftliche Bündnisse und auch verschiedene Bündnisse, ne? Dann gibt's irgendwie, da gibt's die die
Die Linksradikalen Bündnisse, dann gibt's die bürgerlichen Bündnisse, dann gibt's irgendwie gab's jetzt mit alles allen, ein hedonistisches Bündnis und was eher so auch aus der Musik und Clubszene kam,
Und die machen dann Sachen, ne? Proteste und dann hat sich das im Vorfeld hat sich dann äh sagen wir, das eher bürgerliche, so Campag und so und
Gewerkschaften, Greenpeace und so, haben die sie abgespalten und gesagt, ja, wir machen eine Woche vorher, damit damit das irgendwie, die hatten befürchtet, dass es Gewalt gibt. Das war so,
Argumentation.
Was auch äh ja, okay? Ähm.
Hatten gesagt da kamen da auch Leute hin, das war dann an dem Samstag ähm da äh vor der.
Ja vor dem Gipfel eigentlich, ne?
Ging es schon los, also das stand in in Hamburg, also eine Woche von Protesten bevor, ne? Also das war so die ist so die Ausgangssituation eine Woche am Stück Demo, Demo DE. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel's insgesamt waren, aber ich glaube, das waren sechzig Demos insgesamt und Aktionen,
die da gelaufen sind.
Noch vom zweiten bis zum neunten Juli war auf jeden Fall eine Menge los. Kann man schon von einer Woche sprechen.
Wir haben eine schöne Übersicht hier in der Wikipedia gerade gefunden, an der wir uns ein bisschen orientieren. Was ist dieses Yes Wee Camp am fünfundzwanzigsten Juni in Altona.
Das war eine, also.
Es war nur eine kleine Demo zur Genehmigung dieser Protest.
Ja, man kann zu der Vorgeschichte schon mal auch sagen, also dass die Vorbereitung dieser Camps, also wenn ich jetzt äh äh die Vorbereitung der Proteste war, so ein bisschen überschattet davon
das die Versammlungsbehörde und die Stadt,
nicht wie sonst üblich bei Gipfelprotesten ein Camp genehmigt hatte. Also wenn man sich jetzt Heiligendamm anschaut, da hat dann die Stadt Rostock, okay, ihr dürft hier und ihr dürft in redderlich und ihr dürft da äh Camps machen und da können dann zehntausend Leute oder dreitausend, je nachdem wie groß die sind
können in den Camps übernachten. Und das ist ja.
Nimmst 'ne Wiese, stellst, stellst Dixies drauf, lässt die Leute da zelten, machst.
Küche hin.
Basierte Küche, kannst die Leute ein bisschen verpflegen.
Genau, ich mein und man muss halt sehen, also dass die die Rechtfertigung warum es diese Camp es geben muss ist, ich habe einen Protest, der über mehrere Tage geht.
Es gibt Leute, die wollen ihre Versammlung, ihre Versammlungsfreiheit,
wahrnehmen und sie können sie eigentlich nur wahrnehmen, indem sie auch einen Ort gibt, wo wo sie, also der ihnen die Möglichkeit gibt, es wahrzunehm.
Ja, außerdem hat doch hier der der saudische König hatte auch das komplette Vierjahreszeiten ausgebucht. Wo soll ich denn dann pennen? Ja? Da brauche ich doch wohl ein Camp, ist doch ganz klar.
Genau, also Camps gehören immer dazu, ob das in Genua gab's Camps, es gab irgendwie Camps, äh in Heiligendamm, in,
et cetera, es gibt immer Protestcamps und das war eigentlich der Standard, dass es Camps gibt. In Hamburg haben sie von Anfang an gesagt, Camps.
Wollen wir nicht dagegen gewalttätige Proteste von aus und haben das dann
versucht durchzusetzen, da wurde dann geklagt, ein großes Hin und Her und da da gab's dann auch Proteste, die Yes Wee Camp war dann äh irgendwie, hey, wir möchten die Camps haben, also die ganze Vorbereitung war
von diesem wir geben euch kein Camp, damit die Demonstranten irgendwie übernachten können, ne? Überschattet und es hat glaube ich schon so einen Grund,
Grundstimmung ausgemacht, dass man so ein, dass viele Leute gesehen haben, hey, die wollen uns hier Steine in den Weg legen, ne? Also.
Okay und da gab's also anfangs eine, da gab's aber dann auch äh Gerichtsurteile im Alphafahnen. Wie war das denn? Dann wurde gesagt, wir wollen dieses Camp. Äh dann hat das Gericht gesagt, ja die,
die Polizei darf euch nicht die Errichtung dieses Camps verbieten, aber wir verbieten euch in diesem Camp zu schlafen.
Ja, das ging also, ja, das ging auch immer hin und her, dann haben die
quasi ein Camp äh angemeldet, dann hat die Versammlungsbehörde gesagt, nö, ist nicht, dann ging's vor Gericht, dann hat's Gericht irgendwas erlaubt, dann
haben sie neu angemeldet, dann ging's wieder vor Gericht, dann hat's Bundesverfassungsgericht irgendwann entschieden, hat gesagt, ja, das gehört schon dazu, aber die Versammlungsbehörde darf die Auflagen machen, das hieß ja auf zwei Zelte, aber nicht schlafen und also äh war dann
ein Hin und Her, so ein Ping-Pong-Spiel, der Unmöglichmachung, ne? Also würde ich sagen, immer so das das ist dann ging dann soweit, dann dass dann äh,
In Entenwerder, das war glaube ich Sonntag, haben Leute halt angefangen,
Zelte aufzubauen und dann ist die Polizei da rein und hat wegen elf Zelten da irgendwie die Leute mit Pfefferspray äh weggeknüppelt und äh für gute Stimmung gesorgt. Ähm.
Und das hat dann in der Stadt so eine,
Zumindest wie ich's wahrgenommen habe, so eine ging das dann los, dass auf einmal zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen, also oder auch also die Kirche zum Beispiel dann gesagt hat, ja, aber oh wir dulden jetzt bei uns an der Kirche,
Wir wir rufen jetzt nicht auf, dass sie hierher kommt, aber wir dulden das und wir machen die Toilette auf und es gibt auch was Kaffee und
Huren und so und haben dann und das hat ist dann so rumgegangen und dann auf einmal waren die Kirchen alle offen, dann hat äh Schauspielhaus äh wurde dann auch geöffnet, da war interessante, da war ein Einsatz quasi von
eine Falschmeldung. Schauspielhaus ist besetzt. Tausendfünfhundert Leute können hier übernachten und dann gingen die Leute halt dahin und wollten dahin und dann mussten die aufmachen,
Dann gehen andere Theater haben dann auch angefangen, gesagt, ihr könnt hier und das hat dann sehr viel Druck ausgeübt, ne? Weil.
C Sankt Pauli hat doch am Ende irgendwie Teile der Haupttribüne.
Auch privat Personen habt ihr von dieser rote Punktaktion mitbeko.
Genau an die rote Punkte, an die.
Leute haben dann so rote kleine Aufkleber an ihre Klingel gemacht und damit signalisiert, dass wenn Unterkunft oder auch andere Probleme oder mal eben einen Schutz suchen oder so weiter, da kann man klingeln.
Ja, ist schon äh beeindruckend.
Ich denke, ich denke, dass es auch, ich meine, wir werden ja noch viel jetzt reden darüber, was da alles äh scheiße gelaufen ist und äh wie problematisch äh das Endergebnis am Ende auch insgesamt sich auswirken wird, aber ich denke, zumindest innerhalb von Hamburg
dürfte ein neuer Grad an Solidarisierung und Organisation äh eine langfristige vielleicht auch mittelfristige Folge sein
natürlich auch was Gutes hat, auch wenn die Umstände dazu natürlich jetzt nicht so schön sind.
Genau, also ich glaube, dass diese Protestwoche hat eigentlich in der Stadt,
hat für eine unglaubliche Stimmung gesorgt, ne? Also ging leider weiter, dann gab's.
Dann dann gab's dieses äh das Hardcornern äh als Aktion, das ist von den hedonistischen Bündnis war sowas wie wir hängen an den Ecken rum, machen Musik, trinken, haben eine Party.
Also das dieses Kornern, das ist Sing, das ist jetzt nichts Neues, das gibt's schon, ich hab schon vorher, also Cornern heißt einfach rumhängen.
Nee, das hat, ich glaube ne, also Korner, du hängst halt an der Straßenecke rum. Also der der Begriff kenne ich schon sehr viel länger aus dem US-Kontext, aber ich glaube in Deutschland war der mir jetzt nicht geläufig, dass.
Glaube in Hamburg war das schon war.
Es kann sogar sein, dass das.
Schon 'ne Bedeutung gehabt und ist hier halt nochmal neu aufgegriffen worden.
Hängst halt an der an der Straßenecke rum, wozeln Getränk dazu. Wie man so, naja, was man so macht.
War auch so, bringt, bringt eure eigenen äh irgendwie Radios mit und aufm äh freien Sender äh bei dem FSK läuft halt Musik und dann kornern alle rum und am Ende,
Ist es ziemlich groß geworden am am vierten Juli war das am Dienstag, waren auf einmal dann mehrere tausend Leute am Pferdemarkt und haben da getanzt und hatten Spaß und dann ist die Polizei mit Wasserwerfern hin und hat die Leute halt vertrieben. Was nochmal in der Stadt,
die Stimmung nochmal äh weil er sagt, so jetzt lass geht's auf die feiernden Leute. Lasst doch die da machen, die haben doch nichts getan. Also er ist überhaupt nicht gegen die Gewalt passiert, sondern die Polizei
nach dem Entenwerder Räumung und so das Ganze äh führte so ein bisschen dazu glaube ich, dass die die Atmosphäre.
Dass die Leute alle sagten, jetzt was ist denn jetzt los, wie die übertreiben total, ne? Und dann ging das weiter, dann äh am Mittwoch gab's diese tausend Gestalten, das war so ein Kunstprojekt
Leute sich so
äh mit so grauen Anzügen quasi in wie so leicht zombiemäßig durch die Stadt sind äh und so diese,
Also sie sah sehr eindrucksvoll und cool aus, irgendwie so einen Kunstprotest und dann gab's abends äh die Demo unter dem Motto, finde ich übrigens ein großartiges Motto, äh lieber tanze ich als G zwanzig.
Ja, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Zwanzigtausend Leute ähm getanzt und mit zick irgendwie Technowagen. Also größte Demo Rave Hamburgs auf jeden Fall. Äh und es war auch wieder bunt und schön und die ganze Stadt war jetzt irgendwie so,
Ah cool, das ist ja hier irgendwie eine schöne äh ein toller Protest, der läuft und so.
Also wer wer zufälligerweise von diesen tausend Gestalten nichts mitbekommen hat, schaut euch das auf jeden Fall an, da gibt's ein paar sehr schöne Videos. Ich finde, ich finde solche, man kann solche Sachen natürlich auch sagen, ah, ist ja gar nicht äh krass genug und so weiter, ja, weil ist ja nur Kunst, aber
Ich finde, dass das sehr passend war und da sehr viel rübergekommen ist und sehr geile Kunstoption.
Ich finde ja auch, dass ein Protest von dem, also gerade von der Vielfältigkeit lebt, dass du die Greenpeace-Leute hast, die mit einem Boot und irgendwie Ding und eine Kugel am ähm am Fernsehturm dort aufhängen,
die nächsten machen 'ne Großdemo und die anderen machen 'ne Kunstaktion und die raven da,
der Ecke rum und also ich find gerade die diese Breite von zivile Ungehorsam symbolisch hier und da und also ich finde das macht grade die Stärke aus von so einem Gipfelprotest. Ähm.
Gerade gerade in Hamburg hat es aber wirklich auch sehr viel
künstlerische Leute da drin, ne? Also dieses tausend Gestalten äh ist ganz klar so glaube ich auch als Kunst,
Aktionen benannt worden, äh die alles allen Geschichten haben auch irgendwie, wenn man sich die Webseite anschaut, da sind wieder irgendwelche Leute am Werke gewesen, die wahrscheinlich aus dem Theaterumfeld kommen oder so und sich mit mit Konzep
Spielkonzept
ähm also die dem die das Ganze schon auf jeden Fall irgendwie künstlerisch äh gestaltet haben. Dieses tausend gestalten waren eben diese lebenbeschmierten Figuren oder was klebt da eigentlich an denen dran.
Ja, die waren so zugelähmt, dieses haben halt so Klamotten angehabt, waren graumähig, ich weiß nicht genau, was es jetzt konkret für ein Material war, aber so so dem Staub war auf jeden Fall mit dabei.
Sind dann in langsam so Zombieartigen Schrit.
Ja, eben explizit nicht zombieartig, das gehörte sozusagen zu den äh Vorgaben. Man sollte jetzt nicht wie so ein Zombie äh Walk da rüberkommen, sondern es ist,
Na ja, es war einfach ein sehr langsames Schreiten, ja? Den genauen Pace erinnere ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Sehr lange gebraucht, weil da irgendwie so äh zwei Stunden unterwegs aus mehreren Orten in Hamburg und haben sich dann halt an diesen Borchert äh oder Borchert Platz getroffen
da gab's dann halt nochmal so eine Abschlussnummer, wo dann einer angefangen hat, sich äh die Klamotten auszuziehen, dann hatten sie halt bunte T-Shirts drunter und das haben dann ganz viele gemacht und ja, dadurch, dass hier auch irgendwie äh glaube ich zwei Stunden dann alle nichts trinken durften da in der Hitze.
Auch ganz froh gewesen sein, dass das alles vorbei war und sind dann irgendwie johlend durch die Stadt gelaufen. Also es war einfach von der Wirkung her sehr cool und äh das hat mir einfach extrem gut gefallen. Aus der Ferne muss ich sagen.
Genau, also bei mir war das auch noch aus der Ferne und ich bin äh,
Wenn ein Donnerstagabend allerdings äh aus Süddeutschland äh Richtung Hamburg gefahren und da für Donnerstag Abend war eben die Welcome to Hell, also willkommen in der Hölle Demonstrationen von von Autonomen angekündigt.
Die sollte vom Fischmarkt äh losgehen und da kam's jetzt in der Situation äh eigentlich.
Ich will ganz kurz haben wir das lieber Tanz, ich als G zwanzig ausreichend gewürdigt, weil das war jetzt auch eine Riesendemo, oder? Da waren doch zwanzigtausend Leute, die war ja größer als Welcome to hell. Also ähm.
Ja ja, du ich, also man da, also man kann, glaube ich, das Bündnis allen allen äh nicht genug würdigen, glaube ich, in in dem was sie es für die,
Mobilisierung und Wichtigkeit, weil die quasi die diesen bunten Protest, aber nicht dieses bürgerlich spießige Ding, sondern das irgendwie cool gemacht haben. Also alles allen hat war halt so ist so, das was das den Protest sexy und cool gemacht hat, glaube ich und,
darf man nie unterschätzen, solche hedonistischen Bündnisse, äh die einfach so eine, so ein so ein Drive reinbringen, der irgendwie und die Demo muss großartig gewesen sein, also alle Leute mit ich.
Also dagegen sein und Spaß dabei haben. Also sowie Loko und Netzpolitik.
Wie wie wurde es zitiert? Es war ich war war auch ganz schön mit mit irgendwie, ja? Wenn wir schon den Kapitalismus nicht gleich abschaffen, dann machen wir doch zumindest die Drogenliberalisierung,
nicht ganz so leiden darunter. Also auch so ein bisschen Augenzwinkern und und ja einfach,
tanzen und Spaß und irgendwie mit zwanzigtausend Leuten, das ist schon eine fette Demo. Also das muss man schon sagen, also zwanzigtausend, die Polizei sagt elf, aber.
Ja, das.
Kennen ja die wir kennen ja die die genau. Zähle, die beiden Werte zusammen und.
Bis dahin hätte alles noch schön werden können.
Bis dahin war alles schön.
Na, bis auf die, genau, also das heißt, man hat eine Ausgangslage, jetzt ist wir haben eine Stadt, die ähm,
irgendwie so sagt, hey, wir gehen hier gegen den den bunten Protest vor, äh mit lassen denen nicht die Versammlungsfreiheit des,
Demos noch verboten, ne? Also durch diese allgemeinen Verfügungszone, ne, also die blaue Zone wurden dann in der Woche irgendwie Demos von Atark, Demos vom Gängeviertel, äh, wurden alle verboten mit der Begründung, ne, also ihr dürft hier nicht rein, weil wenn ihr da
demonstriert, dann könnte ein Konvoi anhalten und dann wird die Chance auf einen Terroranschlag höher. Komische
Begründung, mit der ich eigentlich alle bei Großveranstaltungen alles verbieten könnte. Also.
Bitte bei die ganze Stadt verbieten können mit der Argumentation.
Also aber die Stimmung war auf jeden Fall jetzt so äh würde ich sagen sehr positiv.
Auf ihrem Höhepunkt.
Auf ihrem Höhepunkt, nee, ich glaube, das ist sogar, dass
dass sie noch gesteigert, dann kam diese Welcome to hell. Diemo, ne, das ist jetzt eher so der der Anthrazit äh schwarzfarbene Protest. Äh mehr so so Antifa, autonome Antikapitalistische,
Umfeld, das ist ja auch nicht so schwarz-weiß wie es oft dargestellt wird. Ähm!
Alle Farben. Ähm.
Ähm.
Und der war dann äh das sollte losgehen am am am.
Am Fischmarkt, ne?
Donnerstagabend, genau und jetzt kam stand die Demonstration am Aufmarsch.
Na Moment, ich ich fand da ganz neu was sehr interessantes. Diese Demonstration, ja, wo irgendwie ähm also die die Antikapitalistischen, die
Antifa Leute, was weiß ich. Unter dem Motto Welcome to Hell, wobei sie glaube ich nicht meinten, dass sie die anderen willkommen heißen, sondern das war so das generell, also was ist hier die Hölle, in der wir leben oder so, ne, aber das Motto.
Nicht irgend so ein Sankt Pauli Fußballslogan, der so ähnlich ist.
Also bei Sankt Pauli läuft Hells Bels am Anfang, aber das.
Ich hab sowas gehört, aber ich kenn das nicht, also deswegen kriege ich jetzt die Kurve da nicht. Irgend so ein Bezug hat's.
Oh, ein Jahr, also,
ähm also lassen wir es mal so, also die die Demo stand unter dem Motto welcome to hell jetzt nicht unbedingt, also da stand jetzt nicht irgendwie äh Peace and Harmony dran. Ähm
sagt aber irgendwie wir gehen vom Altona Fischmarkt über die Retabahn zu den Messehallen, wo man am Donnerstag nämlich noch hingehen konnte, weil war ja noch keiner da,
Aber ausgerechnet diese Demonstration wurde ja dann irgendwie, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, kurzfristig ohne alle Auflagen, einfach nur genehmigt.
Also Hartmut Dude ähm oder wer auch immer jetzt dahinter steht, die Versammlungsbehörde ganz Hamburg in Aufruhr und jetzt kommen Leute und sagen hier welcome to hell,
Kommen die Leute in der schwarzen Regenjacke und die Polizei sagt ach so ja, nee, gar kein Problem. Ach so, zum Messehallen wollte, ja, geht ihr am besten hier über die Reeperbahn drüber, ist doch gar kein Problem, ne? Reeperbahn ähm
Und äh und keinerlei keinerlei nennenswerte Auflagen. Man merkte schon so, oh, der ist aber nicht gut.
Nein, das war, das war ja, als es dann kam mit dem mit diesen äh es gibt keine Auflagen, da kam ja schon eine Pressemitteilung. Ich weiß nicht, von äh irgendwie Anwälten, die sagen, oh, da ist irgendwas faul.
Was sind denn normalerweise.
Ist sowas, dass die dir sagen es ist nicht erlaubt Fahnen stangen länger als keine Ahnung, ein Meter zwanzig dabei oder dicker als.
Länger und dicker als. Transparen.
Parente haben die und die Länge, keine, also die können die Auflagen machen, wenn sie irgendwie Unfriedlichkeit erwarten oder wenn sie irgendwie kann ich über die Auflagen quasi.
Ja man kriegt schon Auflagen, du kriegst schon auf, also selbst wenn du hier eine Pipifax Demo anmeldest, kriegst du eine bitte haben sie einen Ordner auf hundert Leute oder so. Du kriegst da also die Polizei kann aufgrund ihrer Gefahreneinschätzung Auflagen erte.
Okay, aber sie kann's nicht nur, sondern es wird halt auch in der Regel immer getan. Irgendwas gibt's immer.
Genau, normalerweise gegt man immer einen Wisch mit Auflagen und da waren auf einmal keine Auflagen drin. Und das ist halt bei der Demo, die
sagen wir mal schon sich sehr kämpferisch ankündigt und wo schon klar war, dass es dass da jetzt die, das ist jetzt nicht die, die super der bunte Piesnickprotest, sondern die Leute, die sind schon nennen sich unversöhnlich mit dem System
Und und die kriegen immer keine Auflagen. Und das war, da war schon im Vorfeld so ein bisschen, ey, irgendwas könnte da schief laufen. Und jetzt.
Passiert eigentlich das, was Duddel zweitausenddreizehn.
Am einundzwanzigsten zwölften zweitausenddreizehn schon gemacht hat er stoppt die Demo bevor sie losläuft ne? Also und,
Was halten harte.
Also das Versammlungsrecht ist ein Grundrecht und dieses zu brechen und den Leuten das zu verwehren ist ein sehr harter Schritt, der eigentlich den der unter den,
Umständen dort eigentlich nicht gerechtfertigt war und was ist da genau passiert? Also ähm,
Jetzt ist dieser Aufmarschort irgendwie zwölftausend Leute,
Davon sind einige tausend, zweitausend war schon ein ordentlicher, großer, schwarzer Block und Teile von dem sind vermummt. Dann kommt die Polizei, sagt, ihr dürft nicht loslaufen, wenn nicht, wenn hier Vermummung angelegt ist, ne?
In Deutschland gibt es Vermummungsverbot, ich darf nicht irgendwie einen Tuch, eine Sonnenbrille und äh mein Gesicht verdecken auf Demonstrationen. Es wurde irgendwann eingeführt, um gewalttätige Proteste
zu unterbinden und die Leute Strafverfolgung einfacher zu machen. Das ist eigentlich so die Idee hinter dem Vermorgensverbot,
Jetzt haben Teile von der von diesen schwarzen Block die das auch abgenommen, es gab immer noch Leute, die vermummt geblieben sind und jetzt.
Totale Minderheit auf jeden Fall.
Ja, also am Anfang waren's sehr viele, die vermummt waren und dann am Ende waren das nicht mehr viele, also wenn man sich die Bilder anschaut, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwie noch mehr als,
Es ist schwer zu sagen, wie viele Leute es waren, aber es wurde dem Folge geleistet, ne? Also diese Durchsage, Aufforderung, eine Veranstalter setzen sie durch, dass die Vermung wegkommt, jetzt wird es und dann wird das gemacht, das
zieht sich alles hin und jetzt entscheidet sich oder vielleicht entscheiden sich schon viel früher die äh.
Die Polizisten, die übrigens auch alle durchgehend vermummt.
Mittlerweile alle durchgegen.
Alle Polizisten vermummt, aber die demonstrieren ja auch nicht.
Aber sie haben ja auch keine Nummern.
Die sind ja auch nicht bewaffnet, von denen geht ja auch keine Gewalt aus. Ähm.
Du hast glaube ich einen entscheidenden, eine entscheidenden Zeitraum hier, wenn ich das richtig aus den Medienberichten entnehme, standen die sich eine dreiviertel Stunde gegenüber,
Polizei.
Ging nicht so richtig los.
Zwei Wasserwerfer, zwei Wasserwerfer, wenn ich das im im Stream von FCMC richtig gesehen habe, zwei Wasserwerfer entgegengesetzt, der äh Marschroute der Demonstration, der so die wollten nach,
Nun sind wir nach Osten gehen. Richtung Osten gehen. Die Wasserwerfer gucken nach Westen.
Und ähm jetzt stehen die sich eine Dreiviertelstunde gegenüber. Die Polizei sagt hier, ähm ihr wisst ganz genau, keine Vermummung und ähm um jetzt auch mal die Argumentation der Polizei zu würdigen. Polizei sagt also es gibt nun mal das äh,
allgemein anerkannte Verbots in Deutschland sich zu vermummen, ist auch selten, also es sind in wenigen Ländern der Erde so, dass man äh vermummt nicht mehr demonstrieren darf. In Deutschland darf man es grundsätzlich nicht,
Ähm die Idee dahinter ist, dass ja aus dem ähm.
Aus der Vermummung heraus Straftaten begangen werden könnten, können, wie auch immer und ähm die allgemeine,
Argumentation ist ja, wenn du hast ja sicherlich nichts zu verbergen, kannst ja auch dein Gesicht zeigen, zeig dein Gesicht, damit wir dich fotografieren können und,
Jetzt stehen die sich da gegenüber, eine Dreiviertelstunde, es passiert eigentlich wohl lauten
Übereinstimmung im Medienbericht und ich äh fokussiere mich jetzt hier auf die Medienberichte von äh Deutschlandfunk, äh NDR und Süddeutsche Zeitungen, die ich im Übrigen für,
absolut ein, also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ist das jetzt äh hier gleichgeschaltete Systempresse oder äh linksgrün versiffte Lügenpresse, eins von beiden, aber.
Bildzeitung war auch der Meinung.
Genau, selbst die Bildzeitung sagt am Ende, die Eskalation ging von der Polizei aus, ne? An diesem Tag in dieser Demonstra.
Genau, finde ich, man muss dann zurück.
Denn die stehen sich gegenüber.
Auch vorher schon bei anderen Protesten.
Polizei sagt, zieht das bitte, zieht die zieht die Vermummung aus. Ähm, übereinstimmt wird berichtet, der größere Teil der Demonstranten in diesen schwarzen Block hat das auch getan. Eine Minderheit nicht.
Und dann wurde einfach gewartet.
Genau und man muss die, glaube ich, die diese Situation an dieser Straße ist so, dass äh die Demonstration steht, eigentlich quasi zwischen einer Häuserfront und einer einer Mauer, die etwa,
zwei Meter hoch ist oder sogar ein bisschen höher, vielleicht.
Sind die Kaimauern, ne.
Also das ist eine eine hohe eine hohe Mauer eingeklemmt, ne? Und vor ihr diese Wasserwerfer und jetzt,
Ist eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt an als Polizei, kann ich jetzt eine Verhältnismäßigkeitsentscheidung treffen. Ich kann jetzt sagen, okay
jetzt sind halt noch hundert Leute vermummt oder zweihundert, das sind zwölftausend Leute wir laufen jetzt los, ne? Das wäre die eine Variante gewesen,
Die andere ist halt zu sagen, nee, das ist illegal, dessen Straftat, was die begehen. Wir machen jetzt äh was und,
was genau dann passiert ist, ist, dass die Entscheidung der Polizei war, wir trennen den schwarzen Block.
Von der Demonstration ab und lassen die Leute, die nicht schwarzer Block sind, laufen. Ähm also,
kann man nicht äh eskalieren.
Weil sie ja, sie standen ja dem entgegen, ne? Also mir, was mich da in dem Stream wirklich gewundert hat, wenn ich da mal verschwörungstheoretisch mich äußern darf. Diese ähm,
Diese Wasserwerfer, ne, die sind ja relativ groß.
Und ist ziemlich schwierig, die Scheißdinger rückwärts zu fahren. Das hast du dann auch irgendwie zwei Stunden später gesehen, als die dann irgendwie mit den mit den Dingern langsam vor dem Demonstrationszug rückwärts hergefahren sind, ja. Ähm,
Meine mein Eindruck ist, die hatten niemals vor, dass diese äh Wasserwerfer irgendwann mal rückwärts vor dem Demonstrationszug her fahren würden, den und die Dinger auf dieser kleinen Ecke zu wenden, wird durch die
dort äh äh stehen denn seit Jahrzehnten oder Jahrhunderten stehenden Häuser und die ähm Kaimauer zu einem Problem. Also für die, für diese.
Weil die sind echt mega groß und mega lang vor allem.
Der Neue Warweg zweitausend oder wie der,
der zehntausend, der ist größeres, äh, größeres Fahrzeug. Ähm, der passt jetzt nicht in jede Parklücke, ne? Und den äh den da zu wenden, weil das war ganz klar, dass das für die eine Einbahnstraße war und ich würde sagen, die hatten zu keinem Zeitpunkt
Arten, die überhaupt die Absicht diese Demonstration gehens laufen zu lassen.
Also nein, sie haben die, also,
Man muss ja auch sagen, die Situation, also die Demonstranten sind eingepfercht auf einer Straße, die von Mauern und Häuserfront äh umschlossen ist. Und jetzt äh entscheide sich die Polizei,
Anstatt zu sagen, komm lass die paar hundert äh vermummten noch mitlaufen oder wie viel's noch waren nach der Zeit äh entscheidet sich jetzt, die Polizei reinzugehen. Das ist eine Sache, da wird ein eigentlich auch ein eine Massenpanik, also,
wir auch in zumindest entstanden ist in Teilen, wenn man sich die Videos anschaut, ähm!
Da wird in Kauf genommen, dass da Leute zerquetscht werden an Mauern. Ich finde, ich finde diese Entscheidung in dieser Situation,
sichtlich gewählt, weil die Leute nicht weg können, weil man dort den schwarzen Block
trennen will jetzt Kind hunderte von Polizisten rein.
Versuchen den Leuten, die die Transparente wegzunehmen, Pfeffern, äh es entsteht eine Panik und die Leute fangen an über diese Mauer äh von oben kriegen die geholfen und werden über die Mauer hochgezogen,
Während die Polizei die ganze Zeit äh auf diese äh auf diesen schwarzen Block oder zwei schwarze Blöcke sind's eigentlich.
Eindrischt äh und.
Und das ist halt Eskalation und ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt äh noch im Auto und habe Radio gehört und dann war NDR Info und der Reporter sagt ja hier
Gewalt geht hier grad von der Polizei aus. Äh das war äh Deutschlandfunk genauso. Die äh auf
am Boden liegende Personen eingetreten. Das also es kam, ist jetzt nicht irgendwie hier Linke in die Media, sagt, ey, scheiß Polizeigewalt, sondern das haben Reporter vor Ort, Korrespondenten, die irgendwie nicht Bock haben, irgendeinen Scheiß zu erzählen. Äh,
und.
Bestätigt. Das war, das war ein Angriff der Polizei auf diese Demonstration, ein brutaler Angriff, ein gefährlicher Angriff, der die in Gefahr gebracht hat, die Menschen, die dort waren und dann geht halt irgendwie fangen an Leute,
auch Flaschen zu werfen, ne? In dieser Situation, wo die Demo angegriffen wird.
Reaktion halt, ne?
Es stellt sich hier
ganze stellt sich da denn jetzt noch? Also es ist ja immer der immer wieder diese Debatte. Stellt sich hier ernsthaft noch die Frage, wer angefangen hat, ja? Also er wird jetzt diskutiert, äh ob jetzt der, ob jetzt der erste Flaschenwurf von von einem Demonstranten ausging
Oder ob der erste äh was weiß ich, Pfefferspray, Tropfen oder äh Schlagstockeinsatz von einem Polizisten ausging. Ich denke, diese Frage
stellt sich mir zumindest an dieser Stelle nicht mehr. Denn das war äh also darauf wird ja jetzt gerade immer ganz viel rumgeritten, ne? Die Demonstranten haben aber angefangen oder äh die Polizei hat aber angefangen.
Genau, das war die Version, die die Polizei jetzt gestern.
Ja, natürlich.
In ihrer Pressekonferenz natürlich gesagt hat, es diese Demonstration wurde von der Polizei eskaliert
der Gefährdung von Leib und Leben von Demonstranten und unter der Verletzung deren
Versammlungsfreiheit unter auch Verletzung von jeglicher Verhältnismäßigkeit. Äh das war eine krasse Fehlentscheidung, das haben alle auch also gesehen und das hat die Leute wütend gemacht und das hat die Leute fertig gemacht, dass man so mit so einer Vehemenz, also diese,
Herr Wendt, das sagt, äh nee, das war wahrscheinlich diese berühmte Deeskalation durch Stärke. Nein, ähm.
Und und das mit diesem Grundding geht's jetzt, geht's jetzt weiter quasi, ne? Die Demo wird äh,
Wird auseinandergetrieben, jetzt entsteht eine chaotische Situation und es gibt die ersten Krawalle dann auch, äh die im Schanzenviertel dann äh quasi toben, aber in der Situation ist es so, hey,
das ist hier
die Polizei macht hier was sie will. Muss ja auch sagen die Polizei macht was sie will das ist ja 'ne Sache die davor schon anfängt. Entenwerder da gab's einen Gerichtsbeschluss, dass sie nicht rein durften und die gehen einfach die Polizei putscht quasi
geht ohne den Gerichtsbeschluss hin und räumt das Ding. Also eine Polizei muss sich an Recht und Gesetz halten. Wie hat es Gewaltmonopol und sie muss sich,
Verantwortlich sie muss legitimieren, warum sie was macht. Sie muss immer das mildeste Mittel äh nutzen, um den Zweck äh um das Ziel zu erreichen und sie darf eben nicht tun, was sie will. Also das ist Gewaltmonopol und das ich glaube, das ist was,
was an diesem ganzen Gipfel letztlich so erschreckend ist, ist wie dieses Gewaltmonopol,
braucht wird, äh da kommen wir später vielleicht noch dazu, was da also aber das ist so der Moment, wo wo die Sache, glaube ich, dann eskaliert.
Ja und vor allem ist es halt die Aufgabe, die Grundrechte zu sichern, sozusagen, vor allem halt der Demonstration und das friedliche Demonstrationsrecht, das ist nicht nur Deutsch, das ist auch ein europäisches äh äh Grundrecht und das, das ist halt zunächst einmal sicherzustellen,
klar kann man dann jetzt sagen, aber nur war aber einer vermummt
Ja gut, dann muss man halt abwägen und abwägen äh ist das jetzt sozusagen das größere Problem oder ist es ein größeres Problem
Leute hier akut in Gefahr zu bringen, das Ganze in so einer aufgeladenen Stimmung äh zu machen und dann diese Demo, von der jeder wusste, dass sie in gewisser Hinsicht so das zentrale,
ähm Demonstrationsaktivitätsmoment dieser ganzen Woche darstellt.
Danach noch mehr als vorher vielleicht, ähm das halt einfach so komplett äh runterzufahren und damit natürlich diesen den Widerstand,
nicht nur zu steigern, sondern in gewisser Hinsicht auch unkontrollierbar zu machen, weil er natürlich ganz klar signalisiert wird, wir,
gehen gar nicht mit, wir äh ignorieren jetzt mal hier euer äh Grundrecht, äh gehen hier auch mit einer Brutalität vor,
das Ganze auch mit einer durchmeditarisierten Präsenz. Ich meine, wenn man sich die
Polizisten da anschaut, dass ich will die gar nicht mehr als Polizisten ausmalen. Also nur weil er noch irgendwo Polizei draufsteht äh kriege ich das noch zusammen mit meinem äh noch nicht mal dann äh mit meinem Polizeibild sozusagen, ja. Also.
Helfer waren das.
Der andere, die andere
also immer also es wird jetzt gerade hier immer ganz ganz sportlich auf die äh linken Gewalttäter und so weiter äh eingedroschen und äh im Prinzip werden ja, also was was du eigentlich gerade siehst, ist mit diesen,
mit dieser zweifellos vor Gewalt, nicht zu rückschreckenden Minderheit der Protestierenden.
Wird der gesamte Protest äh legitimisiert. Und jetzt wird hier irgendwie in der Diskussion, wird jetzt so getan, als hätte die Hamburger Polizei spontan ja äh sich genötigt gefühlt ähm den den schwarzen Block von den,
mit weniger Farben bekleideten Teilnehmern abtrennen zu müssen. Ja? Als wäre das jetzt so ganz so spontan Geistesblitz, wir könnten die trennen, ja?
Ähm das dieses, wir versuchen euch jetzt zu trennen,
damit der Rest äh demonstrieren kann. Das ist jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass du sowas hörst. Das ist eigentlich ein regelmäßiges äh regelmäßiges Vorgehen und gerade dann, wenn das jetzt, wenn du ernsthaft dieses Ziel verfolgst, ja, dann ähm.
Äh dann dann machst du das doch nicht da an dieser an der Hafenstraße da, wo rechts und links eine Mauer ist, sondern dann dann suchst du dir eine suchst du dir einen Ort aus, wo es dir gelingt, die zu trennen? Dann lässt du die halt über die erste, größere
äh Kreuzung gehen, sagst du, jetzt stopp, jetzt einmal Schneise rein und jetzt liebe Freunde, euch prügeln wir jetzt nach links und die anderen nach rechts. So, das ist das Erste
So und die haben das schon hundert Mal gemacht und hundert Mal an Orten, wo das genau, die sich nicht dafür eignen,
wirklich zwei Menschenmengen zu trennen. Zweitens, ähm, wenn du ernsthaft beabsichtigst, ähm, Gewalt auszuüben
gegen Dinge, die müssen wir ja auch immer nochmal hier dazu sagen. Wenn du ernsthaft beabsichtigst, eine Straße zu einem Straßenzug zu entglasen. Wenn du ernsthaft beaufsichtigst, beabsichtigst Autos anzuzünden, dann suchst du nicht, wie hier immer behauptet wird, den Schutz in der Demonstration.
Vor allem nicht zu Beginn, sondern du mischt dich, wenn überhaupt später darunter,
oder du machst das, während alle auf die Demonstration gucken, bist du fünf Straßen weiter und wütest da einmal durch, dauert fünf Minuten Thema erledigt, zu schnell, kann die Polizei nicht äh äh anarchistische Gewalttäterbande sagen, wie du schon wieder weg bist
ja? Also diese beiden Annahmen muss man einfach mal so beide haben ihre Strategien,
sowohl diejenigen, die ähm Dinge zerstören wollen und dabei nicht von der Polizei verhaftet werden wollen, als auch die Polizei, die diesen Demonstrationszug angreift. Und beide wissen, wie man das richtig machen könnte,
beide wissen, wie man das nicht richtig macht. Und sicherlich sehr unklug ist, ähm aus diesem Demonstrationszug, der von der gesamten Welt gefilmt wird, heraus,
geplant äh Straftaten zu begehen, ja? Ähm noch dazu muss man sagen, dass diese.
Diese gesamte Vermummungsgeschichte ist ja äh immer wieder weit diskutiert in Deutschland. Es gibt inzwischen natürlich langsam äh die den Grund,
und und auch sag ich mal legitim nachvollziehbare Argumentationen sich bei einer Demonstration unkenntlich zu machen
machen sehr viele Menschen. Ob die da jetzt im Bademantel stehen mit der mit der großen, bunten Sonnenbrille, äh weil sie wissen, dass gleich der Wasserwerfer kommt äh oder äh sich eben ein bisschen äh martialischer hier äh maskieren,
Das macht einen riesen Unterschied in der Wahrnehmung,
aber die Argumente, der Grund, warum diese Menschen das tun, muss nicht immer gleichbedeutend sein mit, die wollen jetzt hier die, die Stadt in Schutt und Asche legen. So, das denke ich ist.
Ja, also ich ich glaube, also ich würde mich fast festlegen, dass dude Hartmut Dude den Plan hatte, diese Demonstration genau an dieser Stelle zu verhindern. Und ich glaube, das das war ein Plan, er hat,
gestern dann in der Presse erklär äh in in der PK äh gesagt, ja also wir wussten nicht, dass die Leute dann da das war ja nicht in der Planung. Da hat sie hier ein bisschen,
dass die da alle dann rauskommen, ne? Also da ähm,
und ich, ich glaube, das ist halt, also wenn ich der das war, die Stimmung wurde eh schon so, soweit eskaliert,
in der äh in der Stadt, dass dass die normalen Bürger auch gedacht haben, also ich, als ich komme da Donnerstagabend rein, ja? Äh nein, nee, wir bleiben unter dem, ich erzähle das gleich nachher. Ähm.
Aber du, was du gerade sagst, wie er sie verploppt. Wir haben ja nicht gedacht, dass die Leute da rauskommen, ist nämlich genau der Punkt, weil das, was immer passiert, wenn die Polizei dann so eine Demonstration angreift und den die Gewalt
Bereit aussehende Minderheit oder diese, die auch gewalttätig werdende Minderheit. Äh in irgendeiner Form äh wegkanalisieren will, festnehmen will, unschädlich machen will. Was dann passiert ist, die rennen in alle Richtungen.
Und richten dann Schaden an und dann hast du nämlich die Situation, dass die in alle Richtungen rennen. Deine Polizei ist aber konzentriert an einer Stelle und dann
gehen so oder so Straßenzüge zu Bruch oder Brennautos? Genau das hast du nachher auch gesehen und da passt auch dieser Spruch von Dude sehr schön rein. Ja, war eigentlich nicht vorgesehen, dass die über die Mauer klettern können. Wir haben eigentlich gedacht, wir knüppeln die da alle nieder und haben das Problem nicht, dass sie nachher durch die Stadt
äh Renn-und Brandschatzen. Ja, ist aber leider doch passiert.
Ja, ich ich habe der, also diese Eskalationstaktik, ne, die wie,
Die Polizei gefahren hat. Die findet natürlich jetzt nehme ich mir diesem äh die Gewaltaffinstemonstration heraus und sagt, ihr dürft hier gar nicht laufen,
Und das ist, sage ich irgendwie jetzt ein paar tausend Leuten, denen das echt wichtig ist, weil das ist so deren wichtigste Debo jetzt auf dem Dings, ne? Weil sie's, wie wenn man vorher über das verschiedene Spektren geredet. So und die kriegen jetzt in dieser
dürfen halt nicht laufen, werden zusammengeknüppelt und äh kriegen Pfefferspray ab
ohne dass es wirklich eine eine stichhaltige Verhältnismäßige Begründung gibt. Genau, das geht also äh ähm.
Einhellig wird halt eben von außen von der von den Medien gesehen, dass die Polizei eskaliert hat, ne? Also äh und ich fand diese Stimmung, ich kam da Donnerstagabend oder Nachts um eins rein, komme da nach Hamburg rein, ähm.
Und die Stimmung in der Stadt war so äh,
Da ist dann irgendwie haben die irgendwie abgesperrt die Polizei und ein Riesenstau entstanden und du drückst einmal auf die Hupe und auf einmal haben alle gehupt. Das war so eine Atmosphäre,
Du kannst es auch voll an, Zettel, Zetteln haben Leute angefangen, so und dann die anderen auch. Und die war so eine Stimmung von äh irgendwie schon so, ihr könnt uns mal, also das war auch bei Leuten, die da einfach mit dem Auto gefahren sind. Also,
Die Atmosphäre war so ein war eigentlich sehr positiv für den Protest und sehr schlecht für die Polizei, ne,
also das muss man sich so ein bisschen vor Augen halten, dass dann
dass das so die Ausgangslage ist, es sieht jetzt gerade nicht gut aus für Dude und für seinen Vorgesetzten den Innensenator,
Andy Grothe oder an die Grote. Ähm also die stehen gerade richtig scheiße da,
ist so die Ausgangslage Donnerstag nach dieser Demo. Dann gibt's nachts Krawall,
an an verschiedenen Ecken und Enden in der Stadt und für den nächsten Tag, also den Freitag ist,
sind Aktionen zivil ungehorsam geplant,
grab's das Bündnis Block GT und dann äh das Bündnis Shutta und Hamburg blockt äh wollte auf die Protokollstrecken quasi, also sie wollten verhindern, dass.
Dass äh die Delegation und die und die Präsidenten quasi in das in das in die Messehallen kommen,
Und das andere Bündnis wollte eine Hafenblockade machen, haben die auch gemacht, die haben den Hafenverladeding auch ganz.
Irgendwie so ein bisschen verzögert. Ähm so und jetzt wer jetzt ins Spiel kommt, dann morgens, es gibt morgens um sieben los, das war von der interventionistischen Linken, das ist so eine,
Postautonome äh Gruppierung, die sich sehr um zivil ungehorsam.
Also zivile Ungehorsam ist, ist so die äh ist man überschreitet Regeln aber man kündigt es davor an und weiß auch, dass man dafür bestraft werden kann äh und nimmt es aber in Kauf, haben ge.
Aber diese Regeln sind ordnungswidrigkeiten und nicht Straftaten.
Genau, also das, die sagen, da gibt's einen Aktionskonsens, der sagt, von uns wird keine
Eskalation ausgehen, wir wollen keine Menschen verletzen et cetera, ne? Also so eine man macht einen Aktionskonsens, äh an den sich gehalten wird und das ging dann morgens los. Ich war auch mitgelaufen in in so einem
sogenannten Fingern, es gab verschiedene Farben, es gab den den grünen Finger, den blauen Finger und die gehen jetzt durch die Stadt an verschiedenen Orten, durch Straßen und versuchen irgendwann auf eine Strecke zu kommen, auf die,
Protokollstricke, das ist sehr gut organisiert äh gewesen und und sehr, also ich fand das ist unglaublich ähm also so,
sehr ruhig und cool, aber auch bunt und mit großem Gummiquitschen, die aber auch praktisch sind, um sie dann zwischen Polizeiketten auch mal
zu halten äh und Regenschirme gegen Wasserwerfer und so und dann wurde da auf die Strecke gegangen und morgens war schönes Wetter und dann sind die gleich mit,
Wasserwerfern, wir waren da oben am Schlump, irgendwie in der Nähe der Messehallen äh und und,
Blockade, die der Wasserwerfen aufgelöst wurde, ein Kessel und es war aber alles eine sehr äh würde ich sagen, entspannte, also entspannt unter den Voraussetzungen, das Wasser wäre vom Einsatz hin.
Pack die Badehose ein.
Na ja, aber es sind es sind, es ist so von den Bildern, die da entstehen, ist natürlich auch, also ich glaube, wichtig ist ja schon, äh dass so eine politische Auseinandersetzung mit Protest,
ist auch immer ein Kampf der Bilder und du mit dem mit dem mit dem äh äh den Delfin, den aufblasdelfin, der vom Wasserwerfer steht und butte Schirme und Leute.
Delfin.
Und und Menschen, die irgendwie die alle bunt angezogen sind äh äh und und irgendwie dann von Wasserwerfern weggespritzt werden. Das sind so die Bilder, die glaube ich die Mächtigen nicht so gerne wollen,
weil sie immer so einen, dieses David Goliath Ding, ne? Da sind die Waffen,
die kommen mit diesen Dingen und diese behemden, vermuten Polizisten und gegen diese bunte demokratische Meute, die hier irgendwie sich diesem Gipfel entgegenstellt. Und es lief dann,
irgendwann war's aber auch wann die Sachen alle aufgelöst die Blockaden, ich relativ schnell, weil das ist halt,
Wasserwerfer hast du halt auch nicht so eine richtig gute Chance, wenn du mit drei, vierhundert Leuten irgendwie auf der Straße sitzt, ne? Das geht halt nicht so lange gut.
Erwischt worden vom Wasserwerfer irgendwann.
Ich habe mich so ein bisschen zurückgehalten. Also ich war so ein bisschen, aber jetzt nicht ja, ja ich, also ich habe also schon.
Also so ein Wasserwerfer, es gibt wenige, die sagen, das muss ich jetzt unbedingt nochmal.
Na ja, Wasserwerfer muss man der Warweg zweitausend hat glaube ich acht unterschiedlich zehntausend äh zackig auch.
Zehntausend. Der der hat acht, der hat acht äh Spülprogramme.
Tatsächlich es gibt so, es gibt so Regen, dann gibt's die Wand, die Wand ist es, der geht
der der Strahl so in einer äh einem Bogen nach unten und die Polizei kann hinter der Wand
schon stehen und dann zwischendurch wahrscheinlich Pfefferspray raushauen. Dann gibt's verschiedene Strahlfunktionen, ne? Also von nicht ganz so hart bis ich,
spül dich überall hin,
und äh muss sagen, dass die Polizei meistens eher in den drei, vier softeren Modus Modi unterwegs war. Also nicht so dieses ich kräftig am Kopf dann Auges rausgeschossen, Nummer.
Da so acht Stufen, dann oben ist so Gasi, ja?
Oben ist so Stuttgart ein, zwei äh.
Dass die Stuttgarter Linie.
Ähm na ja, also das das war dann eher so beregnend, da ist die Idee, die Leute sind dann nass, dann ist es irgendwie ätzend und dann gehen die auch nach Hause, müssen sich umziehen und so. Ähm.
Aber wenn ihr alle in Badeklamotten mit Gummiente stehen, dann.
Ja das war, es war halt ziemlich warm, also es war und dann ja, das war dann so ein bisschen so hin und her geplänkelt und dann waren dann nochmal fünf Leute, die die Kreuzung blockieren, dann kommen zwei Wasserwerfer auf. Diese fünf Leute außen rum
Vierzig Journalisten, die die ganze Zeit irgendwie da kann man auch nur gewinnen als Protest, ne? Also wenn dann so ein die wurden dann weggetragen und ohne Wasserwerfer ähm,
Ja und es gab seit verschiedenen Orten und so, das war so diese zivile Ungehorsamsnummer, also ähm
die dann lief und ich glaube um zwölf Uhr so mittags eigentlich dann auch schon spätestens durch war, weil dann.
Wobei man ja sagen muss, durch diese Blockaden hat ja dann Melania Trump ihre Nachhilfestunde im Klimarechenzentrum verpasst, ne? Also äh das hätte ja vielleicht, das hätte ja vielleicht noch unser äh Weltklima retten können.
Er muss dazu sagen, dass es tatsächlich äh erfolgreich war, ne? Also es hat zu Störungen
G zwanzig Gipfels geführt, die japanische Delegation musste es verspätet, musste umdrehen,
eine andere Route nehmen. Äh Schäuble hat eine Veranstaltung, die musste ausfallen, weil die konnten die Sicherheit nicht garantieren,
Melania Trump. Also das kam hat schon zur Störung geführt, obwohl er jetzt nicht zehntausende beteiligt waren, sondern diese Finger teilweise mit drei, vierhundert, fünfhundert Leuten unterwegs waren und dann sich einfach.
Mit diesen Fingern, also.
Genau, also diese die Idee ist ähm
Im Gegensatz zu Dudes Linien, wir machen eine Front auf, geht eine Fünf-Finger-Taktik
bei Demonstrationen davon aus, man hat 'n Versammlungsort und man hat dann verschiedenfarbige Finger, man weiß, ich kriege die bei den Blauen mit, die anderen gehen beim Grünen, beim lila und so weiter
und die spalten sich dann auf also nach,
wie die Finger in der Hand und die einen gehen in die Straße, die anderen in die und man versucht über dieses dieses äh äh verschiedenen Orten zu sein, dieses dezentral, nicht als eine Demo, weniger Angriffspunkte zu,
geben und dann quasi Polizeiketten und Absperrungen zu umfließen,
fünf Fingerprinzip funktioniert auf dem Land deutlich besser,
als in der Stadt natürlich, ne? Weil im Land hat die Polizei keine Chance gegen Fünf-Finger-Taktik,
können die machen was sie wollen, du wirst sie immer umfließen, wenn du eine auf 'ne Strecke willst, die drei Kilometer breit ist, die können da können Sie mit Wasser haben, die haben keine Chance, hat meinen heiligen Damm gesehen.
Waren wir in Heiligendamm am Zaun.
Genau, da kommt also da das gibt es keine, sie haben sie haben keine Chance dagegen, aber in der Stadt sieht's ein bisschen anders aus, das lässt sich sehr viel einfacher kontrollieren. Genau, das das war dann, dann gab's ging's ging der Protesttag weiter,
Es gab dann irgendwann so eine Bildungsstreikdemo von Schülern, äh die da wir sind jetzt Freitagmittag, ne? Ähm.
Die dann äh zum Millerntor Platz gezogen ist ähm und.
Und danach gab's so den den Fingern der verschlafenen, also die quasi den Treffpunkt, die anderen Treffp.
Die, die nicht um sieben U.
Blockaden war so sieben Uhr, drei Treffpunkte und dann so, hey, für alle, die es nicht gepackt haben, fünfzehn Uhr nochmal. Und jetzt war praktischerweise am Endpunkt dieser Bildungsdemo und da äh.
Kamen dann sehr, sehr viele Leute an, da waren sie ja fünftausend, sechstausend Menschen, die sich dann da getroffen haben, da hat man aber auch schon gemerkt, so das war so eine Aggressivität in der bei der Polizei.
Polizei, ja? Die hatten aber ja.
Äh also ich ich stand dort mit mit Freunden und es kommt so eine Polizeikette, die irgendwie durch die Menge durchgeht.
Vielleicht zu fünfzig Polizisten. Und neben mir steht eine eine Frau ähm mit einem vier Monate alten Säugling in einem Tuch.
Und ihr Mann mit dem Kinderwagen nebendran und so irgendwann vierzehn Uhr dreißig war das rum oder so. Ich hab's, wird das äh,
ganz genau war. Und dann kommen diese Polizisten der Erste und schuckt diese Frau mit dem Säugling und der nächste auch nochmal und du stehst nebenan und denkst dir, was zum Teufel macht ihr hier? Die hätten einfach außen rumlaufen können. Ich meine, die gehen gegen
irgendwie, also.
Gegen Säuglinge.
Ich habe viel.
Terroristen, ja? Also die könnten alle irgendwann mal.
Ja. Also ich habe ich habe viel gesehen irgendwie schon an Protest, aber es ist immer wieder erstaunlich, wie es Polizei schafft einen wieder zu verwundern, wie gewalttätig sie ist, ne? Also so eine.
Was man ja hört aus allen Kanälen, aus Hamburg ist ja, dass die Gewalt, die von den Polizisten ausging.
So äh von allen bisher noch nicht beobachtet wurde.
Also ich glaube von.
Würdest du das auch so sehen.
Nach allem, was ich in Deutschland gesehen habe, an Protest, ob das erste Mai Geschichten waren oder Heiligendammen oder also von allen Protesten, die ich in Deutschland in meinem Leben spanne, gesehen habe, war das der.
Brutalste und widerwärtigste Polizeieinsatz, den ich den ich gesehen habe
Gesi und und und Genua ist nochmal eine eigene Kategorie, glaube ich, aber von dem was ich in Deutschland gesehen hab,
Ich habe noch nie so einen großen Polizeieinsatz und der Einsatz von so unterschiedlichen und auch so militarisierten Kräften gesehen und
unter Verletzung von so vielen Grundrechten unter Verletzung von so vielen Pressevertretern und der Verletzungen und in von so vielen Menschen durch Polizeigewalt. Also es ist das.
Ist es der härteste Einsatz, den ich jemals gesehen habe? Ich habe noch gestern mit einem Freund äh geredet, der macht seit,
zwanzig Jahren Demonstrations äh Beobachtung für eine Bürgerrechtsorganisation, der meinte so, das war der härteste Einsatz, den ich jemals gesehen habe. Und,
Das kann man nicht wegdiskutieren, egal was passiert. Ich finde in
Bei der Debatte, die gerade läuft, die jetzt sehr überlagert ist von von die Demonstranten oder Protestiere oder Gewalttäter, wie auch immer man sie nennt, haben Gewalt gemacht, was nicht was passiert ist, dann müssen wir nicht wegdiskutieren, aber das legitimiert eine Polizei nicht,
wie muss ich weiterhin an Recht und Gesetz halten? Sie muss verhältnismäßig handeln, sie muss immer das mittel einsetzen,
und das ist bei diesem Einsatz überhaupt nicht passiert. Ich.
Ja, das war ja auch schon weit vor, bevor es zu einer größeren Eskalation kam, war das ja schon die Strategie. Also auch schon das Cornern, was wir am Anfang äh erwähnt hatten. Sie wurde ja.
Also gegen friedliche Menschen wurde da.
Leute, die einfach so rumschauen und die zahlreiche Videos im Netz sieht das ja auch mehrfach belegen, ne.
Also ich versuche da gerade irgendwie einen Überblick zu gewinnen. Das gibt grad sehr viel kollaborative Projekte, die ad hoc irgendwie entstehen, wo Leute das sammeln. Es ist noch nicht möglich, den Überblick über Polizeigewalt zu gewinnen.
Kenne ich, ich beschäftige mich mit Polizeigewalt, nur wirklich jetzt seit fünfzehn Jahren intensiv und ich habe noch nie erlebt, dass man den Überblick verhält, äh, äh, nicht mehr behalten kann über Angriffe auf Journalisten, über also das ist.
Es ist bedrohlich, was da passiert.
Jetzt die Frage, ähm weil man natürlich das auch sehr viel hört und liest, ne? Braucht man sich ja nicht zu wundern. Ähm.
Da wäre, wenn die, ne, die waren die linken Gewalttäter und so weiter ähm ich denke oder was ich gerne diskutieren würde, ist,
Liegt das jetzt daran, dass die Polizisten alle äh was weiß ich, Gewalt, äh Gewalt
trainierte hier ähm
Psychopathen sind. Nein. Ich denke, das ist ein ganz klar ein ein politischer, eine politischer Grund, wie du deine Polizisten auf seinen Einsatz vorbereitest. Ähm ist es auch eine Frage, wie du deine Polizisten,
taktisch einsetzt, welche Einsatzstrategien du fährst, ja? Und ähm
ich kann mir auch sehr gut vorstellen, wenn die Stimmung mal so kippt, ich ich wäre auch ungern
Polizist in Hamburg gewesen. Ich wäre sowieso ungern Polizist, aber äh wenn ich da jetzt in Hamburg,
gewesen wäre, ja und merke, dass die ganze Stadt mich eigentlich für den Buhmann hält
Ähm dann glaube ich auch, dass ich, dass ich nervlich ähm wahrscheinlich,
überstrapaziert gewesen wäre. Aber genau mit dieser psychischen Belastung, der der Einsatzkräfte und da das waren ja zehntausende Einsatzkräfte. Musst du doch.
Auch als als der Einsatzleiter vernünftig umgehen, ja? Du musst du darfst sie auch eben nicht in solche Situationen bringen, wo sie,
irgendwelche ziemlich üblen Angriffe fahren müssen wo sie,
immer wieder die Kontrolle verlieren über die Situation, ähm wo du ihnen irgendwie die ganze Zeit
die ja die ganze Zeit heiß machst, sagst du, ey, wir haben hier alles an Waffen, ihr dürft das alles einsetzen. Ähm und passt bloß auf, dass euch nichts passiert, ja? Du hast dann auch immer wieder diese ganzen schwerverletzten Polizisten mit einem abgerissenen Fingernagel ähm und die Polizei, die immer und immer wieder ein Thema, worauf wir gleich auch nochmal eingehen wollten, die verletzten Zahlen
ähm,
künstlich hochhält. Ja, also nachweisbar falsch, immer drei Tage später merkst du, merkst du's denn doch nicht, fünfundzwanzig Polizisten hier im Tod, sondern einer hat sich einen Fingernagel abgerissen. Also und das macht.
Oder wurden durch Pfefferspray verletzt?
Oder wurden durch Pfefferspray verletzt, ja?
Wirkt hier aber auch, das wirkt hier aber auch auf die Polizisten. Hätte, also ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht deren Gewalt rechtfertigen, aber ich sehe vor allem, dass die die Verantwortung dafür liegt auch bei oder liegt insbesondere bei denen, die einen solchen Einsatz,
anführen, die dafür sorgen, dass diese Polizisten auch diese Angst haben, das sind nicht alles nur Sadisten.
Es ist noch ein ganz anderer Punkt. Ich sage allen meiner Erfahrungen bei Beobachtung und Teilnahme von Protesten ist je härter die Politik.
Etwas unterstützt von hinten dran. Also es gab hier in Berlin mal irgendwie so heavy ever squated ein Airport.
Ojo, das war auch ein Fest.
Ähm da sage ich, war die Idee, das Tempelhofer Feld irgendwie zu besetzen, um das stadtpolitisch irgendwie ins Gedächtnis zu bringen. Da wurde eine harte Ansage damals Wowereit gesagt, das werden wir auf jeden Fall mit allen Mitteln, ich weiß nicht, wer den genauen Wortlaut. Das war der brutalste Polizeieinsatz in Berlin
Bis dato, die haben da wirklich auf friedliche Leute äh eingedroschen äh äh und ich glaub,
hier im Vorfeld war's auch so, jeder Politiker hat gesagt und im wir werden das im Keim ersticken, wenn da irgendjemand äh der war schon so eine hochgeputschte Rhetorik drin, ne? Also von im Keim ersticken im Zusammenhang mit
Trationen. Also da ging's darum, natürlich die gewalttätigen Sachen in keinem zu stehen. Aber es ist so, es ist so eine, es hat so eine eine Rhetorik von Eskalation äh.
Auch überhaupt null gelungen ist, muss man ja mal.
Weißt du, genau, dann am am Schluss überhaupt nicht gelungen ist, aber es ist, das gibt so einen, so einen Drücker, dann hast du einen harten Hund,
Duddel, der eh dafür steht, alles irgendwie platt zu machen und es ist so 'ne, der, der, ich glaub, der einzelne Polizist
Der kickt hat einen Befehl ähm und der weiß aber auch, da gibt's Rückhalt für oder gibt's nicht Rückhalt für und je mehr äh Rückhalt,
desto härter wird's halt. Und.
Dann hast du aber auch, dann hast du aber auch einfach mal äh Leute dort, die eben auch äh randalieren. Nicht wenige.
In dem Fall, ja? Also Schanzenviertel ähm sieht komisch aus im Moment, hat einiges gelitten.
Ne, ich ich gehe mir auch mal auf den auf den, auf den Ablauf zurück, oder?
Ja, genau, denn ja, so.
Sonst ist sonst wird's also um den Überblick zu also.
Freitag, also Freitag werden, wir sind jetzt gerade, wir haben die Fingerblockade, wir haben die Bildungsdemo.
Vierzehn zweiundzwanzig, die Mutter, die die geschubst wird mit dem Säugling auf dem Bauch. So, jetzt warten da alle ab, die die läuft noch so ein bisschen die die Bildungsdemo und alle ist denken, na, jetzt geht's bald los mit direkter Aktion, mit zivilem Ungehorsam
strömen immer mehr Leute voll. Der Platz ist voll. Es kommt ein Demowagen rein
ich glaube, ein Linksparteipolitiker hat versucht, dann noch eine Spontandemo anzumelden. Die Idee ist jetzt, also Szenario ist die
Die Staats, die Präsidenten sind in der Stadt, die wollen nachher in der Elbphilharmonie Musik hören und wir gehen jetzt hin und werden versuchen uns,
bemerkbar zu machen. Was ja auch immer so ein Ding ist, ich meine in diese ganzen Situationen, Protest ist ja, hat das Recht,
gehört, gesehen und bemerkbar zu sein, ne? Also äh zu werden und und bemerkbar zu sein. Und in so einer Gipfelsituation wirst du soweit abgeschottet, dass du gar nicht gesehen wirst. Also du kannst ja nur und da war die Idee halt hinzukommen.
Jetzt hat die Polizei die Demo nicht genehmigt, die Spontanversammlung,
jetzt gehen einfach diese fünftausend Leute los und versuchen jetzt Richtung Elbphilharmonie zu kommen,
Und das hat ziemliches Chaos gegeben, also da ging's schon durch Parks durch und irgendwelche Mitwasserwerfer und Knüppelei und auch schon Steine und Feuerwerk, also da ist schon einiges los. Es teilt sich so auf ähm,
Ein Teil geht zu den Landungsbrücken runter, was aber alles mit Wasserwerfern blockiert ist. Der andere Teil äh,
Interessanterweise, das war der orangene Finger von äh von Attac, der hatte am Anfang so dachte, uh, das ist uns zu wild. Wir halten uns ein bisschen zurück. Die haben's dann viel näher rangeschafft, nämlich zum
ist kurz vor die Elbphilharmonie und da gab's dann eine Sitzblockade, das war da war ich auch mehrere Stunden, war auf so einer Treppe in Sichtweite, man konnte quasi an der Protokollstrecke hörbar auch protestieren
und das war lief einige Zeit gut, dann kamen aber immer mehr Leute nach, dann gab's wieder Wasserwerfereinsätze, also es war,
aber halt auch immer auch äh,
also war.
Das war aber, finde ich, war zum großen Teil in so einem Rahmen von zivilem Ungehorsam, also und vor der vor der Philharmonie, das fand ich schon auch gut, da so nah mal dran zu sein und mal die Limousinen zu sehen, die durchfahren und eben auch da äh zu zeigen. Also ich finde ja,
des Grundfalsche an an dieser Abschottung ist doch ich könnte doch als Demokratie sagen guck mal hier demonstrieren Leute,
Guck mal, ihr Scheißautokraten. Bei uns können die Leute das nämlich machen,
vorbei und dann müsst ihr damit leben, dass jemand einen Transparent in der Hand hält. Und ich finde es ja eigentlich, das ist doch eine Stärke, da kann man doch irgendwie sagen, guck mal, wie geil es hier ist. Und um das zu ermöglichen, äh ja, das war nicht äh nicht das.
Ja, wenn schon die Führerin der Freien Welt äh unausgerufene äh sozusagen zu denselben Mitteln greifen muss, wie in Washington DC oder in Istanbul, dann äh ja, was taugt das dann noch als Vorbild, ne.
Ja, also ich finde, da wird da auch eine Chance verspielt, eigentlich zu zeigen, was Demokratie eigentlich heißt. Also das ist, ist schade. Ähm genau, dann äh.
Aber zu diesem Zeitpunkt wurden die Forderungen nach Distanzierung der linken Szene von Gewalttätern laut,
etwas was jetzt schon länger schon öfter gibt, ne? Warum distanziert sich die linke Szene nicht von den Gewalttätern.
Also doch. Hat sie. Ich habe da eine Pressemitteilung.
Die linke Szene hat eine Pressemitteilung verfasst. Dachverband der linken Szene in Deutschland.
Dachverband der linken Szene hab ich gelesen im im Ticker von der Mopo.
Ja, das war also
Nee, mal, wer äh wer ein hohes Record lesen kann von einer Domain weiß, auch wer dahinter steckte. Also die linke Szene verlautbarte in einer Pressemitteilung
Sie distanziert sich also jetzt von den Gewalttätern in Anbetracht der aktuellen Kritik, distanziert sich die linke Szene von den jüngsten gewalttätigen Ausschreitungen, hiermit distanzieren wir uns von den Gewalttätern, sagte Rosa Luxus, Pressesprecher,
der linken Szene in Deutschland. Gewalt sei keine Lösung, so Luxus weiter. Der Dachverband der linken Szene e. V. In Gründung vertritt die regionalen und internationalen antikapitalistischen Antirassistischen und globalisierungskritischen Interessen der linken Szene,
Deutschland. Die offiziellen Vertreter der linken Szene werden basisdemokratisch gewählt und vertreten die,
Konsensual getroffenen Entscheidungen der linken Szene gegenüber dem Schweinesystem. Sie üben als Zeichen gegen die Diktatur der Lohnarbeit,
ihre Tätigkeit als Ehrenamt aus, Presseanfragen nimmt die linke Szene unter Presse at Linke Minus,
Punkt DE entgegen Assala Viktoria Sempre. Ähm hat's auch sofort in den äh in den Tickern des der der Mopo geschafft
Somit war das Thema wenigstens mal vom Tisch, ja? Also das äh war mir eine Freude hier kurz den Beitrag zu leisten, dass äh diese Diskussion äh die also sehr unsinnig, ne? Also sie du kannst ähm.
Die linke Szene ist eben nicht so organisiert wie, dass sie sich äh von Teilen sich selbst zisst ähm,
äh distanzieren könnte und ähm ich denke auch, dass es,
überhaupt dieser Begriff linke Szene schon, schon absoluter
äh Unsinn ist, ähm weil du hast hier eine sehr breites äh Demonstrations,
und das ist nicht alles eine Szene, das ist nicht irgendwie die Szene, die da sitzt und sagt, oh, wir haben aber jetzt hier wir sitzen da abends alle in der Kneipe
der Hippie neben dem ausländischen Steinewerfer und dem Nazi, weil wir hier irgendwie sehen, dass Rechte in Hamburg auch demonstriert haben, wie,
die schon genannte Mopo da jetzt gerade meldet, wobei bei denen bin ich inzwischen vorsichtig, die scheinen relativ viel zu melden, ohne dass ich das mal genauer anzuschauen.
Aber macht nur klar, man weiß es halt nicht so genau, was jetzt die Motivation einzelner ist und diese generelle Verdammung einer sogenannten linken Szene, die es halt in der Form und schon gar nicht in dieser Einigkeit so nicht gibt. Äh jetzt wiederum zu nutzen, um irgendwie so einen Fokus auf Links
Links äh Terrorismus oder wie auch immer das dann genannt wird äh zu denken, das ja ist halt ein Ab.
Das ist aber genau, das ist kein, das ist ein Ablenkungsmanöver und da, also das ist genau dieses äh so wird jetzt also so wird im Nachhinein ähm diese
öffentliche Debatte geführt. Das ist ja, ich meine, das haben wir auch alles seit zehn Jahren, fünfzehn, zwanzig Jahren kennen wir das. Da wird jetzt gesagt, ähm aha.
Du warst beim G zwanzig, du hast da protestiert. Ne, das heißt du gehörst zu dieser zu dieser Krawallbande
gehöre ich nicht, ich habe hier legitime Anlegen, die ich vortragen würde und ich habe äh mit einer bunten Hose demonstriert. Äh aber du wolltest dich den Leuten in den Weg setzen, ja, halte ich für eine legitime Form des Protests. Ah, das haben wir aber hier, das habe ich auch gesehen, das machen die. Also du, du
durch diese ähm Fokussierung auf ähm auf Straftäter, die sich in Hamburg engagiert haben, wird,
jetzt in der in der öffentlichen Nachbearbeitung dieser dieses G zwanzig Gipfels immer wieder versucht,
die gesamte Protestbewegung zu delegitimieren, ja?
Allen voran hier Peter Tauber, der jetzt echt sowieso der Twitter-König schlechthin ist. Erst klopft er auf die Minijobber ein, wenn sie was Vernünftiges gelernt hätten, hätten sie nicht drei Minijobs. Äh jetzt sagt
die linke Szene macht sich durch ihr Schweigen mitverantwortlich an den Protesten, wo ich mich nur frage, lieber Peter Tauber
wenn ich mir mal das Schweigen der CDU zu verschiedenen Themen in den letzten weiß nicht sechzig Jahren Bundesrepublik anschaue, ne, dann,
Dann hat er aber eine eine Schuld auf seinen Schultern. Das kann ja, kann man ja keinem mehr äh keinem mehr
zumuten, ne? Also so wird diese Debatte jetzt im Nachhinein geführt und ich möchte mich hier nicht solidarisieren mit Leuten, die ähm.
Die Schäden angerichtet haben in Supermärkten und auf Straßen und an Mülltonnen. Ich möchte aber gerne nicht.
Genauer ran.
Auf eine Ebene gestellt werden äh nur weil weil ich Kritik an dem G zwanzig.
Also nach den, wie heißt dieser der Fleischhauer bei Spiegel? Sagt er, wer auf die Demo geht, der der macht sich mitschuldig, ist genauso, das ist genauso als wie da hat jemand auf Twitter schön geantwortet, ja, wenn ich einen Döner esse, dann bin ich für Erdogan oder was.
Ich, ich, ich finde dieses Mitenthaftung nehmen äh schwierig und und das ist man muss.
Ablenkungsmanöver, ne? Klar.
Ich meine, das das Problem von Gewaltvollem äh Protest ist natürlich schon äh dass die Debatte immer verändert wird. Und es gibt halt Leute, die die.
Also wenn ich politisch strategisch vorgehe und ich führe fünf null Freitagmorgen quasi, ne? Also die ganze Stadt ist hinter mir, alle Leute, alle Medien sagen, die Polizei übertreibt hier komplett irgendwie,
Hätte man dieses Spiel einfach weitergespielt.
Wenn nichts passiert wäre, wäre heute Olaf Scholz zurückgetreten, der Gipfel eine mega Katastrophe. Es wäre also.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, o.
Und wir hätten die nächsten Wochen, über würden über Übergrund und Bürgerrechte reden. Ich.
Was ist mit so Vögeln wie diesen, ich weiß, kenne jetzt die Person nicht, das ist wie weiß ich, aber es gab diesen sogenannten Sprecher der Autonomen, der dann irgendwie äh,
so schlimm ist das doch gar nicht, bloß dann doch bitte nicht in der Schanze, sondern dann vielleicht im Blankenese. Damit kommen wir natürlich jetzt.
Gewalt,
ist halt immer die die gibt's ja schon immer bei Protesten und es gibt halt Leute, die sagen, ist mir scheißegal, ob mit eurem Reformismus, ich mache hier Krawall, weil der Staat hat keine Legitimität. Das ist halt illegal, ähm,
Und ich glaub da kann man sich irgendwie da haben sich schon Generationen von linken Szenen zerstritten.
Das können sie gut.
Äh ich glaube aber wichtig ist jetzt nochmal ist glaube ich dieser Freitagabend, also jetzt hast.
Ah ja, du hast diese Situation, sorry, ich bin da wieder reingrätscht. Die Situation ist Freitagabend. Ähm, die G zwanzig fahren sehen teilweise ein kleines bisschen des Protestes und fahren,
Elbphilharmonie.
Gespielt. Beethovens neunte, wo übrigens einem alten toten Hosenfan nicht entgehen kann, ähm dass das ja äh also der Anfang von ähm äh hier kommt Alex.
Ist genau Beethovens neunte. Und äh ich glaube in einige einige Livestreamer hatten da auch die direkt die Assoziation, oder?
Meine es ist einfach mal Clockwork Orange Deluxe, Stanley
Kubrik, also gerade dieser äh Livestream, der da bei Spiegel und NTV lief, wo du rechts immer die das Konzert, so Trump und Konsorten schauen sich irgendwie hören sich dieses Konzert an in der Elbphilharmonie, links die Livebilder aus der Schanze, mitbrennenden Mülltonnen,
dazu halt Ludwig Van, ich meine da da schalte ich doch direkt rüber zu. Leute, wer
ich habe, ich habe das auch so ein bisschen vertwittert und dann Leute haben nicht begriffen, worauf ich mich bezog. Wenn ihr Clockwork Orange nicht gesehen habt
ja, ist ein bisschen hart, aber äh ist ein Meisterwerk und äh sagt eine Menge aus über Gewalt, Problematiken auf auf sehr vielen Ebenen, ne? Also äh aber als man das dann gesehen hat,
muss man sich echt an den Kopf fassen. Science-Fiction Canna.
Und und jetzt kommen wir eigentlich zu der, also das, was jetzt den Diskurs komplett bestimmt, das fängt eigentlich Freitagabend an.
Wie gesagt, plant äh nicht lange vor der Elbfilme, die noch der Protest geht dann irgendwann dachte so, jetzt gehen wir mal irgendwo anders hin. Ähm kommen dann zum Pferdemarkt und am Pferdemarkt ist irgendwie nun
irgendwie ein Punkrock-Konzert und überall ist irgendwie Musik und Leute machen machen äh äh da ist gute Stimmung, war wirklich äh,
Und man sieht aber schon, okay, da sind drei Wasserwerfer auf der Straße und sehr, sehr viel behemmte Polizisten,
Und dann gehen wir da weiter im Pferdemarkt äh,
zu der zu der Weggabelung quasi. Genau, also die Weggabelung zwischen Schanzenstraße und äh Schulterblatt, ne?
Und man sieht jetzt ja, hier unten an dem Park, an der Ecke standen die drei Wasserwerfer und dann die die.
Wir schauen uns gerade hier das Ganze auf Google Maps an, also äh.
Nee, nicht, genau, also hier stehen die, stehen die Wasserwerfer mit dem West.
Wir haben, wir haben Audiozuhörer.
Leider.
Okay, äh.
Am neuen Pferdemarkt gibt's so ein kleines Waldgrübchen, so ein Mini äh Park, der genau dann spitz zuläuft auf äh Schulterblatt. Also eine weiter äh genau.
Und noch eine weitere, die das Ecke genau da. Ja, das ist die Ecke, wo es dann wo ich jetzt.
Hier hat's geknallt, genau.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Okay, die.
Ich versuche. Okay, sorry, pass auf, erklär's einfach so, wir wir fuchten jetzt hier nicht mit mit Google Mep.
Äh genau, das das haben die Hörerinnen und Hörer nicht. Ähm,
Nein, vom Pferdemarkt aus entfernt etwa hundertfünfzig Metern äh gabelt sich die Straße auf und die eine geht da eben zur Flora hoch und die andere ähm auch ins ins ins Schanzenviertel rein.
Und an dieser Ecke genau hier jetzt mittig.
Ecke hör auf zu wackeln mit dem Ding Tim.
Okay. Äh äh brennen zwei Feuer. Äh hundertfünfzig Meter entfernt stehen diese Wasserwerfer und hunderte von Polizisten.
In jeder Straße brennt ein Feuer auf einem Haus mit einem Gerüst, äh was da im an der Ecke ist, äh sind Leute auf dem auf dem Gerüst obendrauf
brennt und Leute bringen da immer mehr Sachen ran und es wird irgendwie ein Kicker verbrannt und keine Ahnung, also ist halt so eine,
Krawallsituation, die aber nicht angegangen wird und
Ich war dort, habe mir das länger angeschaut, ähm Bier geholt und und geschaut, wie auch viele andere Leute.
Eine Flasche in der Hand hast.
Ja, ja genau. Ähm und es passiert einfach nichts eine Stunde lang. Also es wird immer weiter das Feuer aufge.
Polizei ist zu hundertfünfzig Meter entfernt mit Wasserwerfern, ne? Und schwerem Gerät Räumpanzer et cetera ist kein.
Hätten doch löschen können, oder?
Und das einzige was passiert ist, dass ah ich glaube, da ist einmal eine CS-Gasgranate irgendwo hingefallen, aber das heißt, da sind tausende von Leuten, waren da auf der Straße, ne? Ähm.
Und es läuft einfach weiter. Ne, eine Stunde. Und dann dachten wir so, okay, es ist schräg. Also ich nach allem, was was ich an Polizeistrategien kenne, äh ist, wenn ich eine Menschenmenge.
Vorher ist äh.
Wenn denkt, dann kommen die. Ne, also das ist ja, wenn dann Feuer ist, dann kommen die äh und und löschen das oder sie werfen Tränengas rein und löschen dann oder sie fahren mit einem Wasserwerfer vor, verscheuchen die Menge und löschen das Feuer dann. Ähm das alles passiert nicht,
Passiert nicht eine Stunde lang, passiert nichts. Normalerweise auch andere Sache bei, wenn's Krawalle gibt, Ausschreitungen
Das erste, was die Polizei macht, ist Zufahrtswege zu machen, damit der Zustrom von,
neuen äh Interessierten quasi, also ob das jetzt Deckungsmasse, so wie es die Polizei in der Entdeckungsmasse, das sind ja die so Leute, wie ich, die dann da rumstehen und gucken,
quasi die irgendwie so die dann nicht nicht mitmachen, aber da rumstehen und das interessant finden. Ähm.
Und dann äh also normalerweise versuchst du den Zustrom zu machen. Auch das ist nicht passiert. Wir sind dann von von dieser Ecke mit den zwei Feuern noch weiter hoch, sind zur Flora, wo keine Ahnung, vier, fünf Feuer äh am Laufen waren,
Tausende von Menschen auch dort,
Und da ist halt auch nichts passiert. Währenddessen wurden dann die Läden da geplündert und so und der Zustrom zu dem Viertel, in dem's gerade übeln Reval gibt,
ist einfach nicht zu. Man lässt da Leute weiter rein. Und das ist polizeistrategisch nach allem, was ich von von wie Krawalle verhindert werden,
oder irgendwie ausgehungert werden oder bekämpft werden, ist es so, ich lasse die Leute nur noch in bestimmte Richtung abfließen, ich guck, dass die irgendwie sich aufteilen, ich schaue aber, dass die nicht,
neu zuströmen in das Gebiet, was gerade Krisengebiet ist.
Es sei denn, du willst sie alle auf einem Haufen haben.
Genau, jetzt ist die, die große Frage ist ja, also die Argumentation der Polizei war,
bei den zwei Feuern, das Haus mit dem Gerüst, da konnten wir nicht hin,
denn es war ein bewaffneter Hinterhalt gelegt, so dass unsere BFI-Einheiten BFI ist Beweissicherung und sind Festnahmeeinheit, das ist eine Eliteeinheit zu der Bereitschaftspolizei, so das Härteste an,
was so auf der Straße normalerweise einem begegnet. Ähm,
die wollen da angeblich, die wollten da nicht rein, weil zu gefährlich, weil auf dem Dach waren Leute mit an Betonplatten angeblich und mit Molotovcocktails angeblich. So,
Was mich wundert ist warum gehe ich da nicht einfach mit den Wasserwerfern hin.
Warum löscht ihr da nicht einfach, ne.
Warum nutze ich dann nicht? Ich mein,
Hamburg ist nicht so Tränengasfreundlich, die machen Wasserwerfer und Pfeffer und so, aber die ist nicht so, dass sie so Kartuschen so viel machen. Das ist nicht so die Strategie in Hamburg, aber das wäre da vielleicht auch angesagt gewesen.
Ich vermute.
Das die Idee, das war auch eine Sache, die ein Bildreporter von Polizisten gehört hatte, war wir lassen das jetzt hier so lange laufen, bis die Politiker wieder in ihren Hotels sind.
Weil man quasi die Sache,
also äh man hat die hat man weiß, die sind jetzt da, die gehen jetzt nicht zur roten Zone, die gehen nicht zum Hotel vom Erdogan, die gehen nicht irgendwo wohin, die sind nicht in der ganzen Stadt verbreitet, sondern wir haben sie alle,
Die ganzen Leute jetzt hier im Schanzenviertel und das geht jetzt drei Stunden, strömen da immer noch Leute zu. Du kannst noch Stunden später äh kannst du da kannst du dazu strömen.
Und jetzt kommen die ersten äh Meldungen rein, irgendwie so, oh äh es kommen jetzt Sondereinsatzkommandos und geh da bitte raus, es ist wird gefährlich. Wir ziehen hier extrem viel Kräfte zusammen und so. Es dauert aber drei Stunden bis.
Der Krawall im Keim erstickt wird, ne? Also also bis es war eine äh also ich.
Ich weiß, die Kräfte waren ja da, also mich mich wundert und man hätte auch, wenn diese bewaffnete Hinterhalt an der einen Ecke ist, dann muss ich halt durch eine andere Straße rein und da dann irgendwie die Leute wegspülen mit Wasserwerfern, aber es gibt.
Aus allem, was ich da gesehen habe, eigentlich kein,
Erklärung dafür, dass nicht versucht wurde, die Leute auseinander zu treiben, äh
vorzugehen, vorzurücken mit Polizisten äh und diesen Krawall zu beenden. Und es jetzt gibt's viele Leute, die sagen, ja, die wollen ja die Bilder haben,
kann sein, dass der Herr Dudel und äh Herr Grothe diese Bilder gebraucht haben, weil die Stimmung in der Stadt war ja, ey, die Polizei äh übertreibt hier, die übertritt ihre Rechte und sonstwie. Da sind natürlich so Gewalt,
super, weil danach redet keiner mehr über die Polizei, die über die äh Stränge schlägt, sondern halt eben über,
die Gewalt machen. Ähm,
Es kann sein, dass es polizeitaktisch äh,
Die Idee war, dass es uns für uns das Wichtigste, wenn jetzt das Schanzenviertel abbrennt äh oder auf der Straße brennt, es ist ja auch die die Darstellung ist natürlich insgesamt haben wir in Hamburg fünfundzwanzig Autos gebrannt,
sind nicht zehntausend Autos, die da wegbrennen. Äh.
Und und also es ist auf jeden Fall mir nicht erklärlich, Polizeitaktisch.
Warum man nicht diesen Krawall, warum lasse ich den drei Stunden laufen? Man muss dazu sagen, da waren schon auch gut organisierte Leute, äh,
drin äh die die Polizei angegriffen haben. Also es war jetzt nicht so eine klassische
feiernde Biss auf Fraktion, da waren schon organisierte Autonome, die auch gezielt irgendwie Sachen gemacht haben. Also das war jetzt nicht
Und jetzt passt jetzt auf einmal ins Spiel kommt, sind an der Ecke ähm äh jetzt kommt auf einmal ein Sondereinsatzkommando ins Spiel. Mehrere,
Also es kommt eine österrei.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt stehen die immer noch nur an der Ecke oder sind die jetzt auch schon reingezogen in die ins Schulterblatt?
Ich bin dann ich bin ich bin raus über Umwege äh ein bisschen wieder zurück zum Pferdemarkt so
aber zwei Seitestraßen weg, weil ich dachte so, boah, wenn das jetzt alles so auf Eskalation und es kamen so Nachrichten rein aus dem Mediacenter
Ey, pass mal auf, die machen da Massaker und äh SEKs ist werden eingeflogen auf dem heiligen Geistfeld und so. Und SEK, das sind halt die Typen mit diesen diese wenn ich irgendwie Terroristen bekämpfen will oder irgendwie
organisierte Krimin,
Trazia beim Drogenbaron. Äh also das sind so die Kräfte, die ich eigentlich nie auf der Straße sehen will, weil bei wo normale Leute irgendwie rumlaufen. Ähm.
Auch auf Twitter ausführliche Diskussionen von irgendwelchen Waffenfachleuten, die wissen welche Gewehre die jetzt hatten, ob das jetzt Tränengas, Granatschuss haste nicht gesehen, Gummi.
Maschinenpistolen, also das ist echt so die harte Nummer, das ist so das härteste, was die Polizei so zu bieten hat. Ähm.
Das passierte am nächsten Tag ja nochmal, obwohl die Situation weniger brenzlig war, dass sie nochmal irgendwie SEKs einsetzten gegen irgendwie feiernde, die der dann die dahingehen, sagen, schießt doch, ihr wollt, wollt ihr Tote oder was? Und vertreiben das SEK, also es ist, ich, da,
nachfragen, wenn da eine Untersuchungsausschuss oder parlamentarische Anfragen, dann muss.
Den Freitagabend irgendwie es muss geklärt werden warum darf,
Krawall, drei Stunden laufen und dadurch diese Intensität bekommen, die er hatte äh und dieses diese dauerhaftigkeit, warum wird er nicht früher reingehen? Die Polizei ist am nächsten Tag.
Die Frage stellen dabei wirklich alle, ne? Also das ist irgendwie nicht äh.
Das muss geklärt werden und der Grund, da sind ist ein bewaffneter Hinterhalt, okay, wenn es an der einen Ecke ein Hinterhalt ist, weil mit den gepanzerten Dingen durch. Oder ich mach.
Die hatten doch auch diesen neuen Panzer da.
Ja, ja, das Survival wurde auch eingesetzt. Es wurde alles eingesetzt, es sah aus wie in Amerika, teilweise, ne, mit diesem militarisierte Polizei, Sturmgewehre. Du hast so eine so eine Enthemmung von auch von von Polizei, finde ich, also von von Verhältnismäßigkeit, wo ich denke so, okay
Aber ihr könnt doch jetzt nicht also die eine Sache ist oben auf dem Dach irgendwie die die
angeblichen Molotovcocktailwerfer oder die mutmaßlichen Plattenschmeißer irgendwie
mit dem SEK zu holen, die andere ist auf dem Pferdemarkt, die zwischen feiernden durchpatrollieren zu lassen. Das ist eine Demonstration der Stärke, da geht's nur darum, wir zeigen,
wir holen jetzt hier das ist irgendwie eine eine,
eigentlich ein abgewichseter Exekutive wie geil sie sind. Und wie stark sie sind und so eine Demonstration der Stärke. Und das hat nichts zu suchen auf der Straße finde ich. Das ist
sind neue Qualität und das ist der Präzedenzfall und die haben ja gestern schon gesagt, dass sie das jetzt immer wollen, wenn's so abgeht. Und jetzt haben wir auf einmal eine militarisierte Polizei. Finde ich,
hochschwierig und äh.
Ja, also und am nächsten Tag dann wieder, also das war war total unerklärlich, weil am nächsten Tag wartest du wirklich eher so dieses erlebnisorientierte Jugendliche, die wieder am Pferdemarkt und die angegriffen wurden, ohne dass du weißt
Hier ist keine einzige Flasche geflogen und auf einmal kommen drei Wasserwerfer oder zwei äh und,
spülen die Leute weg und du denkst so, na, was ist wie es gibt gar keinen Grund dafür.
Und die Polizei dann gesagt hat, ja also da wird ein Supermarkt geplündert. Oh und dann eine Stunde später, ah waren eine Fake News, aber wir haben deswegen die Wasserwaffe eingesetzt.
Also die hatten mit.
Also der hat mit Hubschraubern, wir haben Hubschrauber am Ding, wir haben Zivilpolizisten überall, also das ist halt äh also,
Ich, es braucht eine ausgiebige Untersuchung dieses Polizeieinsatzes auch äh und generell der Vorkommnisse, um da zu klären, was da eigentlich,
passiert ist.
Okay? Jetzt haben wir aber noch den Samstag vor uns.
Genau, der Samstag.
Ähm ja, Samstag ist Großdemo-Tag. Äh es kracht jetzt, also hat jetzt Freitag die ganze Nacht irgendwie gekrach,
in die Morgenstunden ist da Krawall. Ähm.
Und jetzt am Samstag äh ab elf Uhr geht es los mit Kundgebung und eine Großdemonstration, da kommen zirka fünfundzwanzig äh fünfundsiebzigtausend Menschen hin, das ist eine ganz bunte Demo. Ihr macht hier immer Scherze, wenn.
Nee, nee.
An der Videowand.
Keine Scherze. Es ist.
Grenzenlose Solidarität statt äh G zwanzig. So die hatte abgezielt, auch wenn ich das da war, also das war die größte Demonstration, ne?
Demonstration, genau. Größtes Bündnis auch unser.
Weiß ich nicht, wie viel wie also da wäre hunderttausend vielleicht auch noch drin gewesen, wenn man nicht das äh wenn man nicht jetzt irgendwie bei dem
bei dem ähm Welcome to Hell schon irgendwie sehr stark eingeschüchtert, weil sie sich kenne von weiß von vielen Leuten, die nach dem,
nach dem Welcome Tour Helding gesagt haben, also dieses grenzenlose Solidarität statt G zwanzig am Samstag, da habe ich eigentlich fest im Kalender gehabt, aber
Nach den Bildern in den Medien, nachdem was da in dieser Stadt los ist, möchte ich dann.
Aber ich kann andere Leute, die gesagt haben, ich komme jetzt extra hin.
Andere sind deshalb gekommen, am Ende laut Veranstalter sechsundsiebzigtausend laut Polizei. Fünfzigtausen.
Fette Demo, eine fet.
Fette Pego. Also es ist bunt.
Große, bunte Demos hat ewig gedauert, die lief dann die Reeperbank untereinander, Parallelstraße wieder hoch. Hol du siehst irgendwie die Demo und das Ende ist noch gar nicht, als das also das war, war eine große
äh Demo, die auch angegriffen wurde von der Polizei. Also es war doch jede Demo angegriffen, also fast sogar bei Tanzen, äh bei äh,
übertragen sich als G zwanzig wohl gab's auch, Wasserwerk, also grad wurde immer alles angegriffen. Hier wurden Leute aus dem kommunistischen Block quasi raus, weil der sich jemand vermummt hatte. Dann haben sie da sind sie rein, haben Leute rausgezogen
dann die Demo lief irgendwie auf dem Millentorplatz,
da war eine Bühne aufgebaut und es war irgendwie alles so piesig und hier so Infostände, Fressmeile, so ein bisschen so Großdemo halt, ne? Wie man das so kennt. Irgendwie ganz bunte Leute, alte Leute, junge Leute, also so der Querschnitt der linken Gesellschaft quasi,
der Linken sonst so ein Spiegelbild davon und dann ging das, dann gab's irgendwie die Wagen und dann
Und dann ging's schon wieder los mit mit Polizeiprovokationen. Also da ist der Endkundgebungsort und da geht so ein Park runter und in dem Park sitzen jetzt Leute hin und auf einmal kommt irgendwie,
solche behemmten Einheiten und fangen an Leute zu verhaften.
Einzelne Leute zu verhaften, führt natürlich sofort immer dazu, dass alle Leute aufspringen und dann Chaos und dann wird der Wasserwerfer, dann wird Wasserwerfer gegen die Einkundgebung eingesetzt, kurz irgendwie, also das
eine permanente äh also es war immer so eine Bedrohungssituation, dass immer alles wird irgendwie angegriffen, ne. Ähm wo man sich halt auch überlegen muss, in so einer Situation
Muss ich jetzt den einen jetzt an der Stelle festnehmen, äh wenn ich gerade fünfzigtausend oder siebzigtausend Leute auf dem Platz hab und es droht dann zu eskalieren mit
tausend Leuten, also ich meine, das sind halt so Verhältnismäßigkeitsfragen, die sich eine Polizei irgendwie stellen muss, wenn sie nicht irgendwie auf Eskalation aus ist. Ähm.
Ja, es ist dann letztlich alles gut gegangen, es gab da eine Sitzblockade vor Wasserwerfern ähm.
Die sehr schön war, das waren auch mal so persönliche Szenen bei all der Gewalt,
Weil dann Leute sich so viele Schüler und Leute sich hin und es wurde gesungen und Helm ab, Helm ab,
und nach einer Dreiviertelstunde ziehen diese Polizisten den Helm ab und unter Applaus und es war mal äh also es war eigentlich so das einzige Versöhnliche, was ich irgendwie auf diesem ganzen Ding gesehen hatte, äh,
Was gezeigt hat, wie man's eigentlich auch hätte machen können, irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Gab's denn ja auch eine Situation, dass sich dann irgendwie ein Polizist und ein Demonstrant irgendwie umarmt.
War sehr schön. Also das war so eine totale Hippie-Nummer, dann kamen noch so Haare, Christnas dazu und.
Die hier wird Bella Chau gesungen und damit Akkordion, also was gab es, es gab auch wirklich schöne Sachen, also ich muss jetzt machen wir mal den Teil den den nicht Gewaltteil, dann können wir nochmal mit,
Mit dem ganzen Polizeigewalt, den am Ende dann, komm, es gab auch wunderschöne Sachen. Also, zum Beispiel, äh, eine so eine Jodel,
irgendwie, die sind halt auch so hinter so Polizei,
in den hinter Polizisten hergelaufen, also hinter so so Polizeiketten mit Domus, nicht Bulle sein, Holladio,
Mach doch was anderes. Wer doch Zimmermann und mit so Quetschkommoden Jodelstyle,
gab eine andere Szene auf den, wo einer so einen Clown hatte auf der auf der Reeperbahn ging auch so Polizeiketten durch die Menge und hatte immer so hatte so eine Tüte mit mit Bananenschalen dabei und hat die dann immer so vor die Hin und sie so Hände gerieben
und gewartet, dass einer hinfällt äh,
so so eine ähm Polonesen hinter den Herren, aber dann haben sie keinen Spaß verstanden, haben sie sofort auch wieder Pfefferspray rausgeholt. Ähm also es gab auch, es gab sehr viele.
Äh die gibt's ja immer Unmengen. Wir beide äh betonen das schon gar nicht mehr, weil wir das ganz normal finden, aber wenn du ähm also,
der der Humor in in dieser dann doch ja irgendwie Zehntausende nicht,
äh nicht in irgendwelche Gewalt äh verwickelten Menschen. Der Humor, den den so eine Demonstration aufbringt, der ist schon echt fein, ne? Das geht von irgendwelchen Leuten, die,
Schild hochhalten, wo draufsteht, ich bin Anwohner, ich will nur kurz zur Rewe, vielen Dank, ne
Ähm über Leute, die eben mit mit äh Schwimm-Delfin und Bademantel anreisen, ähm es gibt schöne Videos von einem Radfahrer, der mit so einer Trompete äh durch die Stadt fährt und die ganze Zeit tatütata spielt,
ähm es also.
Ja, das ist ein, als es ein Feuerwerk.
Mengen an Spaß, ja.
Es ist ja ein Festival der Demokratie. Eigentlich es ist, ist es ja ein auch ein Feuerwerk von von tollen Ideen und lustigen Sprüchen und irgendwie, ich habe gestern noch irgendwelche gesehen habt
so ein Schild was rumliegt, lag mit irgendwie Liebe deinen Nächsten wieder ein Auto,
Also es gibt, es gibt, es ist,
ist ja total bunt und lustig und solidarisch und es war also,
geht halt immer unter, dass das einen, dass das ein unglaublich toller Protest ist, wo Leute auch lernen, wieso wie Protest eigentlich geht und dass man so viel unterschiedliche Menschen auf dem Haufen hat, die irgendwie einen Missmut ausdrücken, aber auch irgendwie zusammen lachen können
Äh das ist natürlich geht in solchen Krawall äh Bildern äh natürlich immer immer unter. Ähm.
Die auch offenbar irgendwie, also die verfangen ja offenbar besser, ne? Also diese äh die Berichterstattung über die äh über die Krawalle in Hamburg. Die waren ja sowas von.
Omnipräsent in allen Medien, dass ähm.
Irgendwie so als also es kam natürlich auch von von meinen Eltern sofort nochmal die wo bist du,
musste ich dann sagen, bin da und da. Ähm aber dann habe äh einen Tag später, habe selbst ich angefangen und habe irgendwie dir und äh anderen Freunden, die in Hamburg waren, äh besorgte Nachrichten geschrieben, habe gesagt, haltet euch da fer,
das war so omnipräsent, während eigentlich ja offenbar, wie man bei diesen sechsundsiebzigtausend am Samstag sieht, mindestens mehrere zehntausend
nicht in nicht annähernd, auch nur in der Nähe von gewaltbereiten Menschen,
In Hamburg waren die dort protestiert haben und protestiert haben. Seit spätestens Mittwoch.
Also ich ich finde was was jetzt so so schade und schlimm ist ist halt äh dass man dass die.
Diese Atmosphäre, die wirklich gut war und die ganze Stimmung, die ist so gekippt, dass ihr euch jetzt in den Kommentaren anhören werden, vielleicht, wenn's irgendwelche Leute falsche Leute reicht. Wie könnt ihr und ihr habt jetzt hier die Gewalt nicht zu ausreichend besprochen und verurteilt und kickt wird wieder so eine
Diese Debatte ist so komplett überlagert und jeder muss sich jetzt die ganze Zeit distanzieren davon. Man kann nicht mehr über die,
du darfst die Polizei nicht mehr kritisieren, ne? Olaf Scholz gestern,
Also, in den nächsten Wochen nicht die Polizei, Unisono, äh.
Ja, die haben alle Familien und sind normale Menschen und so. Genau. Mhm.
Wird die deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft, genau. Jetzt hört mal auf, die Polizei zu äh zu kritisieren.
Du lass ich mich gerne drauf ein. Ähm, kritisieren wir die Verantwortlichen. Fangen wir an mit Olaf Scholz. Also die, ja, ne, dann, also dann kritisieren wir die Polizisten.
Das muss ihm ja alles ein innerer Hafengeburtstag gewesen sein.
Ja, ich meine, du bist eine sehr blauäugige Ansagen, dass man das alles nicht merken würde. Also ich würde ich nochmal auf diese Bewertung, ich glaube, was wir noch nicht hatten, ist irgendwie diese ganzen was dafür, also was da an Gewalt passiert ist oder an an.
Rechtsverletzungen, ein mutmaßlichen Rest vielleicht verletzt, muss man vielleicht sagen, weil es wird werden sicher Gerichte auch klären. Ähm,
Ich finde, das hat eine neue neue Qualität und äh die geht,
das erste ist diese Militarisierung der Polizei, Sondereinsatzkommando bei.
Demonstrationssituationen oder Protestsituationen.
Dann dann haben wir haben wir noch nie gekannte.
Gewalt gegen Journalisten und da muss man auch sagen, dass die was die am Freitagabend, ne, also in dieser Krawallsituation,
Twittert die Hamburger Polizei, wir fordern alle äh Privatpersonen und Medien auf, jetzt nicht mehr zu filmen und zu streamen. Und.
Dann weißt du, jetzt geht's rund.
Ich finde das eine unmögliche Ansage von der Polizei. Es war die dringende Bitte, die wurde dann gefragt, also geht's noch? Spinnt ihr eigentlich? Irgendwie dürfen wir nicht mehr berichten oder was? Nee, ist nur eine dringende Bitte.
Dringende Bitte wird dann umgehend von,
von Polizisten so, dass sie mit Pfefferspray gegen gegen Journalisten vorgehen, dass sie Leuten, die die äh Journalisten gekennzeichnete als Journalisten, Ministerauswahl, gekennzeichnet Menschen,
die die Kameras aus der Hand schlagen, das Sondereinsatzkommandos irgendwie auf Fotografen zielen,
irgendwie, ne? Also mit mit ihrem, mit ihrem Schnellfeuerwaffe, weil die irgendwie da Film oder Fotografieren. Das hat eine, das, diese dringende Bitte wird ja auch Post wenden sofort irgendwie, ersetzt die haben,
offensiv Journalisten angegriffen in Deutschland auf äh also ich ich finde das eine eine.
Muss man noch dazu vielleicht für die Nichtdemonstrationserfahrene bei so in so einer Situation hat die,
hat die Presse einen Helm auf, wo Presse draufsteht.
Vor Presse drauf steht und die offizielle Akrid.
Press für falls weil ja internationale Polizei auch da ist, hast du Press da stehen.
Und da haben meistens noch so ein Bändchen um, also so ein Bad mit mit so einem mit einer mit der Akkreditierung und Presseausweise im Anschlag, so damit man das schon sieht und man kann die schon erkennen. Äh wenn man nicht irgendwie, wenn man's erkennen will, ähm,
Und es ist auch so, dass.
Die Presse das Recht hat bei Polizeiaktionen auch hinter den Absperrungen und sonst wie darüber zu berichten. Das ist ihr gutes Recht und das ist,
kann nicht die Polizei irgendwie A durchdringende bitten und B durch den Einsatz von Gewalt gegen Demonstranten, das hat er also, gab ja nicht nur die Gewaltdemonstration. Ich ich suche gerade die Sachen auch zusammen, ne, diese ganzen
Videos und Fälle und es ist noch nicht überschaubar, wie viel Fälle von Gewalt gegen Journalisten es gab.
Geht ja noch, geht ja noch weiter.
Es geht nicht genau.
Geht ja noch weiter, denn jetzt könnte man ja immer noch sagen, ja äh ne war dunk.
Eifer des Gefecht.
Wanke war dunkel, der äh der Journalist sah vermummt aus, äh hätte also der Blitzkette auch der Lauf der Mündung, das Mündungsfeuer sein können oder so, ne? Könnte man immer noch sagen, ähm dann standen sie aber, ich glaube am
am Samstag dann an der an dem Eingang zum Pressezentrum,
Und habe mit einer langen Liste und die Leute kamen rein, zeigten ihre Akkreditierung und ach, habe ich weggenommen,
Da wurden mehrere Journalisten, die Akkreditierungen wieder weggenommen.
Genau, weil sie.
Unter anderem einem Futter, einem Fotografen des Weserkurier. Ähm du, also du fragst dich, äh eine Akkreditierung ist ja sowieso ein Witz. Du brauchst ja keinen, also du brauchst ja keine Akkreditierung. Äh.
Die Sache ist die, was mit den Pflichtsiegern nochmal auf die Pressefreiheit auf so Gipfelsituationen die ähm.
Die machen seit seit ein paar Jahren quasi nochmal über deinen Presseausweis hinaus
Akkreditierung, das heißt, du gehst davor, meldest du dich an beim keine Ahnung, ob das Innenministerium in dem Fall ist,
guten Tag, hier ist mein Name, ich hätte gerne eine Akkreditierung, zeigst den Pressausweis und dann machen sie eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung und sagen okay
Herr XY darf da reingehen, ne? Also.
Da das ist also da, das heißt das Pressezentrum vom G zwanzig
Das ist das, das ist dann irgendwo bei den Messehallen in der Nähe des Gipfels und da hast du dann auch Zugriff auf die Pressematerialien des Gipfels. Da finden dann äh was weiß ich äh Pressekonferenzen statt, dann kommen die raus und sagen hier äh.
Also das Pre.
Erdogan hat sich wieder was ausgedacht ähm und so weiter. Also du hast dann ein Pressezentrum, so hat man bei Veranstaltungen.
Genau und und da haben sie einfach Leute hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich linksorientierte äh Journalisten und Fotografen äh dann einfach rausgeschmissen und es gab halt wirklich so eine lange Liste von quasi durch Sicherheitskreise und Geheimdienste,
als als disqualifiziert. Also der Geheimdienst so das BKA bestimmt dann, welcher Journalist berichten darf.
Das,
Thema war ja so groß, ähm also was Leute anging, die keine Akkreditierung bekommen haben, dass sich das FC MC,
gründet hat das freie Medienzentrum, was im
Millan Torstadion stattgefunden hat, wo sich noch einmal fünfhundert Journalisten mal kreditiert haben, ja? Die also also.
Siebenhundert waren's glaube ich sogar.
Oder siebenhundert, also wo da können natürlich jetzt auch die,
offiziell akkretieren, das hat sich ja gegenseitig nicht ausgeschlossen und als Journalist Akademisier, aber da waren eben äh da war also ein Medienzentrum mit äh Streammöglichkeiten, da waren Computer für die Leute, dass sie irgendwie äh Sach,
laden können, Podcastwunder produziert, das Ganze mit sehr starker Unterstützung des Chaos Computerclubs, der hier denke ich äh sehr äh gelobt werden kann. Ähm,
Aber das ist so ein Beispiel für das Medieninteresse, was du in dieser Stadt hast, ne, dass du nicht irgendwie vereinzelte
vereinzelte Journalisten. Und jetzt gehen die auf einmal hin und äh verwehren akkreditierten Journalisten, die irgendwie den ganzen Zinova schon hinter sich hatten, ohne ohne großartige Nennung von Gründen ähm.
Aber du bist jetzt auf.
Du darfst jetzt hier nicht mehr bei den Großen spielen.
Ja, also das das ist der eine Punkt, das ist auf so einer offiziellen Ebene.
Schien öfter Fotografen zu treffen, hatte ich subjektiv den Eindruck. Ja. Wahrscheinlich den Fotografen, die nachmittags dachten, ja okay, jetzt fotografiere ich das nächste, den ich äh Philharmonie durfte ich ja nicht mit rein.
Ja und dann hat sie meine Chefreporter der der Bild-Zeitung, ne? Also einer sag.
Den haben die ja kreditiert.
Der Linken, der der Linken Sache unverdächtig wahrscheinlich äh,
dem haben sie angedroht, wenn du den nicht hier weggehst, dann kommst du kommst ins Krankenhaus und so. Also auf der Straße, also das war jetzt nicht äh also auf der Straße ist es ein unzähliges.
Waren denn das überhaupt noch Hamburger Polizisten.
Das fragen wahrscheinlich alle möglichen oder.
Oder waren das einfach mittlerweile alle nur noch irgendwie so aufm ich will jetzt keine Region nennen, aber.
Nach Sachsen gab's auch, haben wir auch gesehen, aber äh also das weiß ich, welche Einheiten das genau waren, aber es.
Ich meine, wenn die sich da schon Österreicher da irgendwie hingestellt haben, wie wie kam es denn dazu überhaupt? Also weißt du das da österreichische Polizisten? Was haben die denn in Deutschland zu suchen.
Ne, die haben Österreich, sie wollten niederländische, die niederländischen haben aber wohl, also jetzt muss ich bisschen glatt als, weil ich nämlich nicht,
haben abgesagt, weil ihnen die rechtliche Lage zu unter war. Während die Österreicher halt.
Denen ist die rechtliche Lage, egal.
Ihre SEK-Sondereinsatzkommando ähm äh Cobra dort rumhantiert irgendwie hoch bewaffnet. Ähm, aber also das mit den Journalisten, dann,
als dritten Faktor von diesem welchen erste Wahl,
die Militarisierung der Polizei, das zweite, die Übergriffe auf Journalisten, das dritte ist, Polizeigewalt, also es gibt Szenen.
Wo wo Menschen da ein Beispiel. Da sitzen sitzen irgendwie ein paar Menschen, das ist zwanzig Leute sein in der Sitzblockade vor einem Wasserwerfer.
Ähm jetzt habe ich verschiedene Möglichkeiten als Polizei damit vorzugehen. Wir normal würde ich davon ausgehen, okay, das Erste, was ich mache ist.
Trag die weg oder.
Vielleicht erstmal reden, wäre vielleicht mal.
Genau, gehen sie weg, sonst ähm aber es war wahrscheinlich schon die Räumungsaufforderung schon da,
als wenn die bespritzt mit Wasser und die sind aber ziemlich standhaft gewesen beziehungsweise sitzhaft und hing da rum und haben weiterhin so,
Was jetzt kommt, ist da gibt's ein Video, finde ich, das härteste Pfefferspray Video, was ich,
in Deutschland je gesehen habe, da gehen mehrere Beamte hin und besprühen die über,
zehn Sekunden, zwanzig Sekunden so richtig hardcore mit mit Pfefferspray. Das ist einfach, das wird, wenn das Gerät vor Gericht kommen würde, es ist rechtswidrig, das ist nicht das mildeste Mittel, das ist
ultra brutal und das und das ist nur ein Ding. Ich hab.
Beim Sammeln dieser Videos jetzt gerade so brutal irgendjemand läuft vor so einer Polizeikolonne, also so eine fahrende Polizeikolonne und läuft so ganz langsam und will die blockieren.
Zumindest verlangsamen.
Oder verlangsamen? Steigt ein Polizist aus und haut haut den,
heute einfach und du hast, du hast so und diese Videos, da kommt jetzt extrem viel, wo Leute bewusstlos durch die Gegend geschliffen werden, so mit aufgerissenen äh aufgeschürfte Beine und die
nicht mehr bewegen, wo Leute äh also eine Polizeigewalt das Polizeigewalt gibt schon immer äh aber,
das Ausmaß. Also ich ich weiß nicht wie viel wie viel Videos da am Ende zusammenkommen werden von unglaublicher Gewalt gegen Demonstranten, die nicht recht zu, also.
Das hat man ja auch schon erwähnt, ne, aber das ist eben jetzt auch noch bewusst Journalisten trifft und es ja auch mehr als einen Fall gibt, wo er auch die Polizisten dann nun noch dazu gesagt haben, mit ist mir, ich.
Pressefreiheit gilt jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, die Formulierung kriege ich jetzt alle nicht auswendig, aber so verschiedenste Formulierungen, die im Kern halt sagen, es ist mir egal, dass du ein Journalist bist und hier irgendwelche Rechte genießt, die interessieren mich jetzt halt mal einen feuchten Kehricht. Und.
Das hat nichts zu passieren,
Also das ist das ist das ist einfach das das kann nicht passieren und vor allem kann eine dafür verantwortliche Führung nicht sagen es wäre schon alles okay, weil das ist nicht okay. Das also es ist nicht nur nicht okay, das ist halt einfach schon mal Biont okay.
Du siehst irgendwelche alte also nicht nur bei Journalisten. Ich finde ja eigentlich äh die Demonstranten, die genießen auch äh das Recht irgendwie, dass
das mildeste Mittel gegen sie einsetzt und hast dann eine Situation wo eine Straßenecke stehen drei Leute, ist irgend so eine Polizeiräumungssituation und dann knüppeln die einfach auf diese Menschen mit dem Knüppel ein, wo du denkst, okay, weil
Die haben doch jetzt gar nicht irgendwie euch angegriffen und so, ne? Das wird also so eine.
Da wird's sehr viele Fälle geben und ich weiß auch, dass irgendwie Menschen jetzt dahinter sind, da eine Seite zu machen äh und ähm um da das zu sammeln und um einfach diese diese extreme,
harte, harte Polizeigewalt, die da vorkam,
Was ist das nächste Ding, was der Gipfel glaube ich wirklich, was hart war, ist halt diese Einschränkung von Versammlungsrecht an, wenn ich irgendwie die halbe Stadtsperre für Demonstrationen.
Ist äh.
Kann ich nicht machen. Es wird so viel Grundrechte mit Füßen getreten von zehntausenden Menschen auch,
äh das das geht nicht, das ist einfach. Also und ich habe.
Also einfach vom vom das Gefühl jetzt hat, dann wieder weg zu sein ähm äh und und zu sehen,
Okay, das war jetzt das härteste Ding und es wird niemand kritisieren können, weil alles überlagert wird von der Debatte, die noch eine Verschärfung fordert. Also,
wegen der Krawalle, die die jetzt nicht zu rechtfertigen sind und durch nix, aber äh äh dass jetzt noch also das, dass es heißt, die Polizei darf nicht kritisiert werden für den härtesten Einsatz seit zwanzig Jahren oder noch länger. Äh
das das kann, das kann nicht sein und die Debatte jetzt geht er noch weiter, ne? Also jetzt kommt.
Du hast gerade im Vorgespräch gesagt, die die Polizei als eigener politischer Player inzwischen, ne? Also äh früher äh früher in den guten alten Zeiten, ja, die die Polizei äh,
da hat's ja irgendwie nur Einsatztaktik äh auch nachher erklärt und kundgetan und ähm du du sagst jetzt die die Polizei tritt.
Anders auf.
Ja, also fängt an mit wie, wie sie auf Twitter agiert, ne? Also da hatte ich ja schon vorhin bei, wann waren das diese Protest EZB
mir mal das genauer angeschaut hatte, wie die auf Twitter,
agieren, also das früher war's halt so, okay, es gibt einen Polizeisprecher, der vor Ort bei einem größeren Protest, eine sagt dann was und am nächsten Tag kommt die Pressemitteilung und da schraub schreiben die meisten Journalisten dann ab. Ähm.
Und ich und jetzt ist die sind sie auf Twitter unterwegs und
machen in Echtzeit, eine Kommunikation. Und ich glaube, man muss aber, dass es jetzt auch noch nicht verboten, da muss man über die Grenzen kennen von dem, ne? Also ist das eigentlich äh erlaubt, dass die Leute blockieren, die ihnen kritische Fragen stellen oder wie, was ist da eigentlich
Muss ich mich duzen lassen bis hin zu irgendwie wie weit nehmen sie den Einfluss auf einen laufenden Protest über ihre Kommunikationskanäle, ne? Also ist ja was anderes weil ich so direkt.
Direkt irgendwie da die Leute anspreche und auch die Meinung. Also es kommt sehr oft so eine Meinung mit rein, ne? Wo die, wo die quasi so. Geht überhaupt nicht oder irgend so eine so eine, so eine, so eine so eine.
Machen jetzt ihre eigene, ihre eigene Kommunikation.
Und beeinflussen den laufenden Diskurs über Proteste quasi, ne? Ähm,
hinzukommt, dass die Polizei als eigener politischer Player, ich denke, was in Hamburg passiert ist, die haben da vertreten halt ihre eigene Interesse für so wie das gelaufen ist, ist,
Herr Dude vielleicht ja ganz gut raus und der Innensenator aber also da muss man jetzt ja aufpassen, die Polizei, die sich selber, die Polizei ist eigentlich ein Handlanger des Staates und nicht ein eigenes Ding, was was ein Eigenleben entwickeln darf
und man hat gemerkt, dass sie sich in dieser Rolle dieser starken Polizei schon auch gut, also es war so der der ganze Eindruck, der über diesen Gipfel schwebt, der war
Das finden die schon auch geil, was sie jetzt machen können, was sie wollen. Und das kann.
Ja, die Polizei hat selten äh um Beschränkungen äh ihrer
den Möglichkeiten geworben und wir können uns darauf einrichten, dass das jetzt äh dieses Mal auch natürlich passieren wird. Wir sehen also
Zeichnet sich jetzt heute am Montag schon ab. Ähm noch sind alle Forderungen noch gar nicht auf dem Tisch, aber wir haben jetzt irgendwie Heiko Maas äh fordert ein Zeichen gegen G zwanzig Krawalle, nämlich Rock gegen links.
Das ist ihm aber von der Bild-Zeitung, in diesem Facebookvideo so ein bisschen in den Mund gelegt wor.
Völlig egal.
Vielleicht nochmal, na ja, sollte uns jetzt, äh, bevor wir es nicht genau genau gehört.
Nachrichten kommen jetzt noch gerade bei uns an, ja? Ähm also Rock gegen Links wird echt witzig, wird lustig. Ähm
Peter Taube habe ich ja gerade schon gesagt, der äh gibt jetzt den schweigenden Mitschüler und du siehst, die sind.
Also was auffällt, ist jedem, der da war, jeder, der das irgendwie mal, der sich das einfach mal anschaut, auch diese, wie gesagt, beim SC MC gab's dann auch so einen größeren Stream von dem,
äh von dem Fischmarkt, wo du einfach auch, sage ich mal, siehst, welche Gruppierungen agieren wo und wie. Du siehst ganz einfach diese äh,
Gewalttäter sind 'ne absolute Minderheit, ne? Aber du siehst die ganz klar in der Kommunikation jetzt grade so die tun
die spielen die Karte jetzt absichtlich, dass jeder, der da protestiert hat. Zumindest mitschuld ist, weil er nicht, weil er sich nicht von Gewalt distanziert hat, obwohl das vielleicht hunderte Male äh Geschehnisse, die Menschen äh ganz woanders waren, aber.
Es ist geschehen auf der Großdemo sind Leute mit, so ich kein Bock auf Gewalt und so.
Ja, das gilt ja aber nicht. Wir wollen eine offizielle äh eine Office, ne? Also da wirst du jetzt in so eine wirst du jetzt argumentativ in so eine Ecke gedrängt, aus der du gar nicht rauskommen kannst, ähm wo jetzt, wo jetzt eine.
Sagt er, ist, ich ich finde es schwierige daran, dass jetzt so getan wird, als könne man nicht,
Es gäb's nicht die Position, die Gewalt auch scheiße zu finden, aber die Polizei trotzdem zu kritisieren.
Keine Zwischentöne, du kriegst irgendwie auf Twitter irgendwie so Dinger und jetzt gar nicht und da schießt die und wa? Und es ist so die Zwischentüte. Ich natürlich kann ich in einer Demokratie
sagen äh Gewalt
zähliger Protest finde ich Kacke, aber eine gewalttätige Polizei, die macht was will, finde ich auch Kacke. Und ich muss mich doch nicht auf die Seiten unserer Polizei rüberschlagen irgendwie, nein, das ist die Polizei und die muss kontrolliert agieren und die muss ich rechtfertigen für das, was sie macht und ich finde, also ist für eine unmöglich die Debattenkultur mit Hans-Peter Friedrich,
Die Journalisten sind die Hintermänner dieser Dinge und äh.
Also ich meine Hans-Peter Friedrich, schlimmer.
Egal, lassen sie sich über ihn re.
Na doch, das musst du einfach, weil ich kann jetzt keiner mit sich nicht bieten lassen, ne? Ähm ähm der Stern schreibt einen Artikel
mit dem Titel Beamte des Bundeskriminalamtes haben mehreren Journalisten die Akkreditierung entzügen entzogen ohne Begründung. Ja, Hans-Peter Friedrich immerhin mal äh Innenminister und Agrarminister dieses äh wunderschönen Landes twittert.
Schlimmer als die hirnlosen Gewalttäter sind die geistigen Hintermänner, die ihnen die Rechtfertigung für ihren Terror liefern. Das ist, das ist Trump-Niveau.
Entgrenzung Terrorbegriff.
Redet doch jetzt vom NSU und dem Beitrag der CSU.
Der redet, der redet, der redet vom Stern und bezeichnet den Stern als geistiger Hintermann des Terrors. Ähm erstens mal gibt's ein glaube ich.
Aber es ist eine Entgrenzung des Terrorbegriffs, das hast du in der Pressekonferenz gestern war dann auch so, ja,
Terrorismus und sonst wie, nein, es ist eine durch eine,
Eskalative Polizei und Politik und Polizeitaktik hervorgegangene Sache, die irgendwie. Also ich ich will das gar nicht entschuldigen, aber es gibt fast ganz verschiedene Facetten, die dazu geführt haben, dass das so gelaufen ist, wie es gelaufen,
es ist nicht also Terrorismus ist halt doch was anderes. Also.
Genau, wichtig ist, wenn man hier eine Debatte führen möchte
dass man ähm die Macht der Sprache nutzt, um verschiedene Phänomene auch unterschiedlich zu benennen. Und den Definitionen treu zu bleiben. Und das, was man da in äh in Hamburg in der Schanze gesehen hat, war scheiße
Da sind irgendwie,
Supermärkte geplündert worden, da sind Dinge angezündet worden, da sind Menschen auch körperlich angegriffen worden, ähm dass das nicht als Terror zu bezeichnen, ist aber nun mal einfach
das Waren von Begriffen. Ja, es ist, was da stattgefunden hat, ist kein Terror.
Das, das heißt aber nicht, dass das gut war, ähm aber das heißt auch nicht, dass es äh dass es Terror war,
ist nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension und ich habe keine äh also es es tut der Debatte nicht gut. Wenn jetzt irgendwelche ähm Tiefflieger
Ähm hier die Begriffe vermengen und alle sagen, ja, das sind jetzt hier Linksfaschisten und hast du alles nicht gesehen. Wenn du die Begriffe vermengst und alles einfach nur noch,
und Eindimensional siehst, wie es hier gerade geschieht, dann kommt da, kann,
gar keine vernünftige Debatte mehr stattfinden, kann gar keine Aufklärung in der Situation mehr stattfinden, weil du die Diskussion der Begriffe beraubst. Und das passiert, wenn man jetzt irgendwie geht's alle G zwanzig Gegner als gewaltbereit äh diskreditiert, wenn man irgendwelche
Diskreditierung von Gruppen verlangt, die es nicht gibt. Also die Gruppe selber,
Gibt es als solche nicht und kann deshalb auch nicht sich distanzieren von Teilen ihrer selbst, weil sie so nicht existiert. Das passiert, wenn du das jetzt als Terror bezeichnest und insbesondere, was jetzt natürlich sowieso auch schon kommt,
wenn du jetzt dann auch noch recht rechten Terror, ne, mit mit Toten ähm und Angriffen auf Menschen gleichsetzt mit.
Autos.
Brennenden Autos. Das ist auch Scheiße. Das ist auch scheiße. Aber ähm tut mir leid, das sind eben unterschiedliche Phänomene. Und es wäre schön, wenn wir dafür dann auch.
Ja, vor allem ist es auch.
Begriffe bewahren könnten, damit äh jeder Mensch äh sich hier äh ein klares Bild.
Ja, weil wenn irgendwann alles nur noch Terror ist, so und dann haben wir vielleicht auch mal so unseren kleinen, kleinen Strohhalmnetzpolitischen Bezugs äh in der heutigen Sendung, ja,
dann kann man halt auch gegen alles mit Zensur, gegen alles mit online Durchsuchung, Trojanern und so,
vorgehen und dann ist halt dem Ganzen keine Grenze gesetzt. So.
Also ich ich glaube, das das der politische Fallout von diesem Gipfelprotest, der eigentlichen,
Protest war der sehr lange Hoffnung gemacht hat, wird schlimm sein. Die werden versuchen am Demonstrationsrecht, also ich, das kommt doch als nächstes jetzt,
Demonstrationsrecht zu beschneiden. Die wollen Extremistendatei eine europäische, die wollen wurde ja schon gefordert Links linke Zentren schließen wie die Flora oder die Riga Straße irgendwie das ist eine, das ist eine,
eine Wendung hier ins autoritäre die die mir große Angst macht und deswegen ist es glaube ich auch wichtig, dass wir dass wir die andere Seite erzielen und erzählen da ist
irgendwie der härteste Polizeieinsatz gelaufen unter dem Brechen vieler vieler Gesetze, bin ich mir sicher. Ähm und es muss,
Aufklärung rübergeben und es ist schwierig dieses Narrativ jetzt zu brechen, aber ich glaube es ist wichtig, dass wir da, dass da, dass da auch mal zusammengetragen wird, was da passiert, weil
in einer Demokratie kann die Polizei nicht machen, was sie will,
genauso wie auch Menschen protestierende nicht machen können was sie wollen. Und es muss einfach äh es muss darüber muss eine Aufklärung, Untersuchungsausschusspflicht nicht nur in Hamburg, sondern auch,
im Bundestag wäre großartig, um da mehr Einblicke zu kriegen oder zumindest parlamentarische Anfragen und eben dem.
Auf den Grund gehen, aber erstmal müssen wir erstmal sammeln, was da alles passiert ist äh und was da, was dieses Wochenende eigentlich für die Demokratie in diesem Land,
bedeutet und für die Zukunft von Demonstrationsfreiheit, von der Zukunft, von Demonstrieren, für die Zukunft von Polizei.
Ja und Zukunft von Repression und allem, ne? Also ich meine, es wurden Handys abgenommen den Leuten, die sollten die entsperren, das war auch noch ein netzpolitischer Bezug äh also
das ist alles hat so eine neue Qualität, dass ich mich eigentlich weigere über die,
Über die Autos zu reden, die gebrannt haben, wenn ich sehe, was was da für die Demokratie in Gefahr ist, weil die die also die Gefährdung der Demokratie.
Ja, Leute wurden auch danach nicht in Züge gelassen, wenn sie sich nicht Zitate Videografieren lassen.
Genau, also ich glaube, man muss da echt aufpassen, dass man nicht geblendet wird von diesem von diesem Krawall, während hinten rum die äh elementare Grundrechte abgeschafft werden.
Ja und zu zu fordern jetzt aber nicht die in den nächsten Wochen.
Nicht die Polizei.
Sicherheitsgesetzgebung äh verschärfen, beziehungsweise äh in die die Stimm.
In den Wahlkampf nehmen, ne?
Wahlkampf solche Sachen mit aufzunehmen und die Demonstrationsfreiheiten weiter einzuschränken. In dieser Zeit ähm die dringende Bitte.
Kritisiert die Polizei offene, faire, fachliche und gute Art, weist ihn nach, was sie falsch gemacht haben. Es geht nicht darum, den einzelnen Polizisten dabei irgendwie anzugehen. Das ist gar nicht die Frage, es geht darum,
denjenigen, die das Gewaltmonopol haben, ihre Grenzen, die gesetzlich festgelegt sind, auch vorzuhalten, um nicht mehr und nicht weniger und um eben,
Hier unsere Demokratie nicht gegen die Wand fahren zu lassen.
Und damit sind wir bei den Terminen angelangt, wenn sich noch jemand vor der Tür traut ähm,
Darmstadt vom ersten,
dritten September zweitausendsiebzehn die MRM CD siebzehn, die Bundesdatenschau. Äh die Meta Rhein-Main-Chaos Days äh sind die MRM CD. Und äh was ich echt, ich finde, hier dieses Motto mal wieder geil. Bundesda,
echt schön. Die haben auch so einen geilen äh Ankündigungstext, ne, wo dann irgendwie von Arbeit, mit und so weiter, muss man sich angeschaut haben, äh HTPS zwanzig siebzehn Punkt MRM CD Punkt net. Ähm dann gibt's den CFP
da gibt's ein Pre-Sale, das wird ein großer Spaß und am gleichen Wochenende finden nämlich statt.
Eine Konferenz glaube ich von Netzpolitik Org äh ja.
Das ist Netzpolitik, heißt die Konferenz und findet das äh vierte Mal jetzt schon äh statt. Und zwar ja, am gleichen äh Wochenende halt. Erster September,
Und ja, das wird dann mal wieder ein lustiges äh stell dich ein werden von netzpolitisch aktiven, wenn ihr euch auch ähm da aktivieren lassen wollt oder äh andere Interessen habt, die aktiven zu treffen, da hängen sie alle rum und ähm,
Wird schön.
Okay, schaue ich mir an.
Ne. Gut. Dann haben wir das jetzt glaube ich hier eingetütet, wa?
Dann haben wir den Sack zu und können draufhauen.
Ich glaube auf die Säcke wurde jetzt schon genug draufgehauen. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht auch noch machen.
So, wir haben äh vielleicht sollte man das jetzt wir werden für diese Sendung Kritik kriegen, weil weil wir uns hier äh nicht von der Gewaltiert haben, de.
Weil wir noch nicht mal erklärt haben, warum man überhaupt dagegen sein soll, ne? Dagegen sein soll. Ja. Warum man.
Dagegen sein sollen. Und äh was überhaupt beim G zwanzig passiert ist?
Am Ende ist immer die Polizei schuld. Ja.
Klein kleines Twitter, klein Ort, umso Journalist meint, er frei er fragt so einen Protester äh ja äh,
handelt denn ihr was ist denn sozusagen das Thema ihres Prozesses? Antwort? Ja, was ist denn das Thema von G zwanzig.
Ferienoff. Ganz gut.
Aber äh ich denke, es ist ganz klar, worum's hier uns bei dieser Sendung ging, nämlich äh uns alle darauf vorzubereiten, dass äh wir,
Das, was da in Hamburg passiert ist, das wird uns in der deutschen ähm Innenpolitik,
und in den deutschen ähm Demonstrationen der nächsten äh Wochen, Monate und Jahre noch durchaus einige Zeit beschäftigen und deswegen haben wir diesem Thema jetzt auch mehr oder weniger.
Eine ganze Sendung gewidmet. Ähm damit bleibt mir selbstverständlich dir zu danken. John F Nebel.
Danke, danke für die Einladung.
Ja, bitte sehr.
Und Markus, Simon, Steffen und Kai.
Und äh wir sagen tschüss, bis bald. Das war's erstmal wieder. Nächste Woche geht's wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen weiter. Tschüss. Tschüss.
Ciao ciao. Tschüss.
Tschüs.